Õpetaja: Teine video
Õpetaja: Serga.
Õpetaja: Okei, Kumi aina.
Õpetaja: Me jäime sinna maale, et, ee. Me siis tekitasime endale niukse meetodi nagu Get Cities.
Õpetaja: Ja kui see asi annab meile, siis, kui me vaatame ka returniga, annab meile promise objekti. No see on nagu see telefonikõne
Õpetaja: Ei, Saatsin ee. Valisin numbri. Ee, olen seal ooteliinil. Ee, kohe. Keegi vastab sulle. See on promisobjekt, mida tagastatakse.
Õpetaja: Siis nüüd see koht, kus me seda välja. Kutsume seda meetodit siis niimoodi. Ee, see asi põhimõtteliselt tagastab objekti. Kujutage ette, ta tagastabki objekti.
Õpetaja: Objektidel saab kutsuda välja meetodeid, punkti. Ja veel
Õpetaja: siis. Ee. See meetod, mis meid nüüd huvitab, on vend
Õpetaja: unustavad. Ei tähenda pakkuda. Mõtleb seal midagi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lõpuks tuleb veel ja võib siia otsa panna ka, et on meil Ka Catch.
Õpetaja: See on see If Else. Vaata, F.
Õpetaja: Gustav ven. Els.
Õpetaja: Paneme finali ka.
Õpetaja: Kas Sa push Isid. Selle
Õpetaja: bussis on küll. Jah.
Õpetaja: Hetkel, kui on kontroll. Ee, Mm, Bush
Õpetaja: sisse välja. Ühtegi Comiti pole Push Ida,
Õpetaja: et kui Fetch I teed ära, siis peaks olema samal joonel nii või naa.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: See sõnum tagastab promise objekti ven Catch Finali
Õpetaja: Okei, toa ära kõik linnad eesmärgiga.
Õpetaja: See dropdown.
Õpetaja: Vaatame pärast materjalides, kas siin on midagi mis ka veeb? Üheksa kohta veel on?
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis ma vanasti Võibolla veel
Õpetaja: teoreetiliselt midagi. Õpetasin kohe, kui ta siin pildi laeb.
Õpetaja: Sisu kaudu. Noh, kohe räägime seda ka.
Õpetaja: Mm, kõik need asjad, mis ma tahtsin rääkida. Nii või naa.
Õpetaja: Võime neid pilte Veel vaadata pärast ka. Okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd. Mis on meie niiöelda, et kood oleks siin hästi niiöelda niuke puhas.
Õpetaja: Siis Nüüd me tahame toimetada nende sees. Aga me teame samasugust lahendust, nagu me tegime. Log In Views
Õpetaja: meeldetuletuseks. Korra kui minna Login View alla, võib minu ekraanilt vaadata. Seda
Õpetaja: meil jäi see sõnum ise üsna niisuguseks. Ee, lühikeseks saada sõnum. Anna kaasa parameetreid venniga. Me saame Mingisuguse sisu.
Õpetaja: Me tegeleme selle sisuga alammeetodist.
Õpetaja: Handle, Login, response ja error
Õpetaja: ja finalis. Siis, ka kui me mida midagi tahame teha. Arvatavasti selle Spinneri asja Teeme ka aga natuke teistmoodi. Meil oli Spinner nupu sees, mäletate?
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd meil ei ole mingit nuppu. Me saabume kuskile lehele,
Õpetaja: Seal lehel on kaks asja. Seal on Rip menüü. Ja hiljem tuleb üks tabel ka.
Õpetaja: Et ee. Pole vist mõtet enne midagi näidata, kui Veel asjad, laevad.
Õpetaja: Võibolla üks asi, mis siis võiks proovida? Ma ütlen, Kabel
Õpetaja: Spinners. Stable Loading Spinners. Ma vaatan korra kas midagi
Õpetaja: kuidagi niukest On, Ee, mis võiks kõnetada?
Õpetaja: Ei, see ei ole. See Ma ütleks. Image alt. Saaks vaadata üldse? Mine tagasi.
Õpetaja: Nende liiklus vist on kukkunud küll. Ee, väga kohutavalt Ma tahtsin küsida nüüd selle, kas on läbi.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et ma arvan, et ei ole läbi. Ee, aga hiilgejad on läbi. Ütleks nii,
Õpetaja: et kes läheb ikka sinna küsima Mingit asja, et kuidas midagi teha, kui sa saad lihtsalt kuhugi kirjutada?
Õpetaja: Aga, Vaata, Siin ongi see, et siin ikka need inimesed, kes sinna lähevad, tahavad kindlasti arutada vähe level asja.
Õpetaja: Nad tahavad arutada nende teiste inimestega ja Mitte mingisuguse chat. Iga,
Õpetaja: et ma arvan, et sinna jääb inimesi.
Õpetaja: Aga its not gonna be as Nice ee, Nagu vanasti
Õpetaja: tüüp ei saa kuskilt valida. Nagu
Õpetaja: ma otsin ühte erilist spinnerit, mis mulle tegelikult meeldiksid. Kus sealt tuleb lõpuks ka.
Õpetaja: Vot näed, vaata, kas siin on midagi, Mis võiks.
Õpetaja: Enamvähem
Õpetaja: päris pole, aga võibolla ei. Kes midagi siia kanti. Võibolla võime mõelda,
Õpetaja: mis selleks on vaja niukest seda
Õpetaja: Ahah, okei võime mõelda siis, kui jõuame sinna
Õpetaja: nii. Davai Ee, Spinner Spinneriks. Ma lihtsalt mõtlesin hästi natukene ette. Aga põhiline asi on see, et mäletate, saatsime sõnumi. Aga me tegeleme nende ee asjadega. Eraldi meetodite sees. Kui läheb hästi, siis meil on eraldi meetod, kes sellega tegeleb,
Õpetaja: kui meil läheb Halvasti. Meil on eraldi. Me, me tegelane, kes sellega midagi teeb Ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: siis siin. Me tahame nüüd samamoodi teha.
Õpetaja: Esiteks, on meil Siis see süntaks, mis siia käib. Siia käib lambda funktsioon Ehk Funktsioon käib siia sisse.
Õpetaja: See näeb välja selline, aga meile meeldib et ee, Selle välju asemel oleks pigem response.
Õpetaja: See kõnetab rohkem.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me mõtleme. Kui me meetod on Get Cities
Õpetaja: siis siin me tahame öelda, et on mingi meetod, mida pole veel olemas. This
Õpetaja: punkt, mis? Ma kirjutan siia, kui võtta snitti sellest,
Õpetaja: mis meie musta ränd on.
Õpetaja: And A something and a Mis something.
Õpetaja: Kui vaadata nagu login andel Log in response.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd tuleksime siia, siis selle nimi võiks olla handel.
Õpetaja: No lihtsalt respons on. Kui meil on mingi, mil mitu sõnumit läheb, siis mis respons, onju?
Õpetaja: Vaat võib olla siis andel Get Cities.
Õpetaja: Hästi, natuke maitse küsimus. Kas, Ee, Noh, me vaataksime seda nagu Get Cities Response. Aga samas nagu võibolla see üks väike sõna nagu jälle, Nagu meie jaoks. Teeb Selle asja niivõrd palju täpsemaks. Et Paneme nii, mis isegi just meeldib. See rohkem sobib
Õpetaja: sõita. Täpselt. On ju Jutumärgid Tuleb Siis siia jutumärgid. Sul tuleb siis siia juurde panna. Miks, sest plaan ongi? Tahame midagi sinna kaasa anda. See objekt, see sildikene ja See objekt tema taga elavad ja surevad
Õpetaja: siin selles vahemikus.
Õpetaja: Me tahame temaga edasi toimetada. Siis tähendab see, et selle response me anname kenasti sinna kaasa.
Õpetaja: No nüüd ta vingub siin. Vaata, kui talle selle joonekesega siia kontrollid all noortega liigutab, siis ta on nagu hüppeliselt niimoodi paneb, Onju Versus
Õpetaja: seda, saate aru, onju? Umbes kuskil siin, selle kollase joone juures. Olla Siis kollane pirn. Pirnil saab. Vahet pole, mis sfäär saab alati ainult interlaati teha.
Õpetaja: Siis ta pakub, et kas teeme siis ühe meetodi nimega? Meile sobib.
Õpetaja: Tegigi selle siia alla vaid ta mentrite ühe korra veel
Õpetaja: see meetod midagi tagastama. Ei hakka vaid vist ühe korra. Veel entrit niimoodi. Tegin niukse tühja meetodi meile.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma tegin niimoodi, Võtan sammud tagasi.
Õpetaja: Tulin siia, et ta oleks kuskil selle juures. Kus see kollane joon on?
Õpetaja: See tekitab põhimõtteliselt siia Selle pirnikese. Seda pirni saab alati enteriga lahti teha. Aga me ei viitsi seda hiirega teha. Ma ütlesin siin
Õpetaja: valikute seast.
Õpetaja: Saan valida selle esimese.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta pakub. Kas tahad mingit muutu nime muuta?
Õpetaja: Sa tahad, mida ta return Ib et annab võimaluse kohe kiirelt toimetada. Mina panin sealt enter, et ei ole,
Õpetaja: et mul on nagu eraldi need meetod
Õpetaja: nüüd ka koodi suuremaks tegema. Teile ka nii.
Õpetaja: Mm, pea nii palju kissitama, Okei,
Õpetaja: no nüüd On siis see küsimus, et vaata, et me saame selle responsi.
Õpetaja: Jällegi, kui me mõtleme oma piiblile.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see respons on kogu see respons
Õpetaja: Status, kood headerid, mingisugused. Mis iganes. Asjad
Õpetaja: ja Body respons. Seda kutsutakse Respons Bodiks. Aga meil ta. On andmed, data,
Õpetaja: kogu vastus koos sulgede ja karvadega on response.
Õpetaja: Mis me juba on selle sildikese taga. See siin on Data.
Õpetaja: Kas see on arusaadav?
Õpetaja: Vaata, võibolla eelmise materjali juures Oli kuskil Ee, mingi pildikene. Selle kohta võiks justkui olla.
Õpetaja: Siis ma tegin mingit niukest pilti. Ma olen varasemalt seda joonistanud
Õpetaja: ei ole, Noh, Ma võin selle juurde lisada, siis, Em.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ei viitsi seda asja veidi. Kogu see asi
Õpetaja: on okei. Ma teen Cheibilt selle vähemalt
Õpetaja: Ee, nii.
Õpetaja: Mis on maailma kõige parem Ee joonistusprogramm.
Õpetaja: Muidugi, Photoshop on aastaid üritanud järgi tõmmata, aga pole õnnestunud.
Õpetaja: Mm grupp, ka, et teeme Selle väiksemaks Ma panen selle pildi ka siis kuskile.
Õpetaja: See sildikene. Siin.
Õpetaja: Sõnumi saatmine Response.
Õpetaja: Pean selle väikse koleduse väike täpp. Jäi siia? See mind häirima. For life. Nagu mis korda?
Õpetaja: Pole midagi, millega hakkama ei saaks.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: kogu
Õpetaja: nüüd saan aru. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No kuidas tahaks seda nüüd ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Pole midagi, millega hakkama ei saaks.
Õpetaja: Noh, hästi, natuke niimoodi. Aga sa teeme selle ära. Ups,
Õpetaja: proovin kuidagi siit enamvähem õigest kohast hittida,
Õpetaja: saate aru?
Õpetaja: Spons on kogu see asi.
Õpetaja: See on status. Status tekst.
Õpetaja: No tõmbame veel siin. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Praeg. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Siis ta jääb
Õpetaja: suuremaks Ka Teen
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Muutuja sildikene. Selle sildikese sees on kogu asi.
Õpetaja: Ei, usu.
Õpetaja: Palun väga, Ma kirjutan siia Response punkt.
Õpetaja: Ootan natukene.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: ta ei tuvasta neid ära. Aga siin on Response data. Siin on Response punkt. Staatus.
Õpetaja: Seda pakub. Lõpuks pakub staatus siin Response sees on Punkt Staatus
Õpetaja: tekst midagi taolist. Selle all vist panin kuidagi puitu. Vaata, aga siin on erinevad blokid. Meid huvitab eelkõige
Õpetaja: see osa
Õpetaja: nüüd on niimoodi, et niimoodi me saame selle kätte.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ütlen, et praegult hetkel. Siin on see informatsioon olemas. Siin on olemas Kui me jõuame siia lõppu, siis seda enam ei ole olemas. Aga meie missioon on seda kuskil alati hoida.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted siin tekib?
Õpetaja: Noh, see vastus võiks juba tulla.
Õpetaja: Ei see vastus võiks. Ma ütlen, et see info võiks meil nüüd alatiseks siin alles olla.
Õpetaja: Seda nii kui seda infot on niikuinii vaja jagada. Aga kuskil nagu visuaalis,
Õpetaja: mis muuta?
Õpetaja: Siin, on ka mu tee Muuta Palun väga let muuta.
Õpetaja: Täpsustav on muuta küll
Õpetaja: Kas vastab Tõele, et sellest peab lõpuks tulema. Siit tuleb info Linnade info, millest peaks siis joonistama need Selectoptionid. Kõik linnad on ju nii
Õpetaja: vastutajale Noh, Terviseurenswor, mis? Meil on vaja silti.
Õpetaja: Palun. Silt, led, silt. See on ka silt.
Õpetaja: Panen näiteks selle väärtuse, Ka Fine.
Õpetaja: Noh, ei saa öelda, et Ei, ole muutujat.
Õpetaja: Noh, vastus tuli ära. Aga ma nüüd panen ikkagi jälle selle pildi ka.
Õpetaja: Läheb kaua aega teil kuidagi, nagu tegelikult, See võiks juba vaikselt nagu paika loksuda.
Õpetaja: Noh, mitu korda me seda sama pilti vaatame? Nagu eksole, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui ma ütlesin, et me, soovime Seal Dropdown is näha. Noh, see, kuidas kuidas saab näha seda sisu
Õpetaja: meetodites? Me käivitame tegevuse, mis pärib andmeid taga. Saab need andmed soovid seda Dropdown Iks teha
Õpetaja: andmeid soovid näidata. Soovid näidata tallinntartupärnu? Noh, ainult üks moodus,
Õpetaja: et kui te ütlete muutuja, siis ma tahaks kuulda, et Data bloki muutuja. Sest muutuja võib olla Props. Vabandust, et ta, on parameeter. Võib olla kohalik muutuja.
Õpetaja: Keegi võiks seda mõelda, et ratasse vaja panna. Ma ütlesin ka. Soovime neid andmeid siin jäädavalt kuskil hoida. No kus mitte mujal kui nendes väikestes kastides, eksole?
Õpetaja: Okei, noh, kui me Nüüd läheme siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, tatabloki.
Õpetaja: Nüüd oleks mõistlik korra jälle vaadata meie piibli vastu seda. Asja
Õpetaja: siin on kirjas mida, ta tagastab response Data
Õpetaja: Nüüd meil siin koodis on. Jah, vaja ühte
Õpetaja: Meil on nagu põhimõtteliselt vaja. Nagu ära defineerida, et, ee, meil tuleb selle osa mis tuleks Tegelikult üks kandidaat sul ka. Veel Meil tuleb Niukene objekt sisse. Massiiv. Kus sees on? Objektid? Kus sees on? Ee, City, Id ja City Name. See on see mudel, mis me tahame.
Õpetaja: Ee, päris äge. Siis ta juba olekski üksikobjektina. Vaata,
Õpetaja: seal ei ole niukest näidet vaid siin See osa, mis ma see osa tinglikult tuleb ära kustutada. Niimoodi oleks päris väge. Rais. Siin oleks null. Ja siin oleks ennast ring
Õpetaja: ta Nä, ta näitab jaava klassi pealt. Lõpuks Et mida? Ta võtab sisse?
Õpetaja: Kuidas küsime,
Õpetaja: Ee, Okei, teeme selle ära. Esiteks on. See, vaata, et Meil on vaja mingeid muuta nime.
Õpetaja: Vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks selle. Mis võiks olla selle muutuja nimi Ja siin on ainult üks õige vastus on? Siin
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla selle muutuja nimi, Kus hakkavad need andmed elama?
Õpetaja: Miks It list Kuidas saab mitmust veel väljendada Peale sõna list
Õpetaja: All Sities võib olla, aga äkki läheks natuke veel lihtsamaks?
Õpetaja: Cities, Mis selle meetodi nimi on?
Õpetaja: Okei, siis siin on ainult üks vastus
Õpetaja: et Kui ma vaatan seda meetodit, siis ta peaks nagu mingi muu asjaga nagu kokku rääkima. Kui mul on siin praegu tatablokis muutuja Citys ja Mul on meetod Get Cities. Siis ma võin vist aimata juba, vaata, et kuidas. Kus kohast Cities endal sisu saab ilmselt kuidagi selle meetodiga
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on nagu java. Kujutage ette, et see on list City objektidest.
Õpetaja: Kui mina ütlen List Citys ja peame muutuja nime panema, siis Ma valin selle kõige lihtsama variandi
Õpetaja: objekt, mida on mitmuses City Cities
Õpetaja: nii lihtne. See ongi, et ei ole listi vaja
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et me Räägime ikkagi andmetest, kui mingisugune.
Õpetaja: Ee, Noh, ma ütlen nüüd praegu, Identity, või oleme nagu ta on mingi üks infokild, aga ta on mitmused
Õpetaja: Cities.
Õpetaja: Okei, siis korraks. Ee, teen suureks, et teil on parem näha. Tulen uuele. Reale.
Õpetaja: Kirjutangi Citys.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: no nüüd. Kohe saab Hendrik. Või Kes iganes küsis seda. Ma ei mäleta nüüd, et. Ee. Miks mitte mitu? Rida? Vaata ja nii edasi. Kohe. Räägi nüüd sellest ka
Õpetaja: Nüüd siia. Mina tahan nagu aru saada, et mis siin ideeliselt sees käib, ideeliselt.
Õpetaja: Ma ei taha, teada, et seal on Tallinn Tartu pärnu
Õpetaja: ma ei taha teada et seal on tallinntartu pärnu viljandi ja aegviidu. Või ma ei tea, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Need väärtused ju tegelikult tulevad meil üldse Ju
Õpetaja: Back end ist ostad Tabelile. Ma ei Pane neid siia kirja, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga mul on sellegipoolest vaja tegelikult aru saada nagu et Mis, mis objekt siin sees käib?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma nüüd tulengi, võtangi selle niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Selle kogu asja esialgu kopi. No see kopsimine häirib ja ei häiri. Kas see kord on üldse peal
Õpetaja: on väga hea.
Õpetaja: No seda ma ei küsi, et Kas te Screenshare I näete või ta Tahaks ammu juba küsida, Et
Õpetaja: Mida meie. Äpin. Kui me nüüd paneme, selle siia plöraki maha ja seda peate ka tee tegema.
Õpetaja: Natuke Noh, Natuke läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Mul ei olnud see viimane vat. Kui halb on siit niimoodi kloppida.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi, Hästi, ettevaatlikult. Siin ei ole kopinoppo.
Õpetaja: Päris selles juba on. Esiteks, et seal näitab nagu seda väiksemat.
Õpetaja: Nüüd saab, öelda, et see Citys on massiiv
Õpetaja: kandilised sulud. Kurat, ma ei sulgas, koputan Ja vastavalt nii,
Õpetaja: ma olen päris palju seal koputavad. Ma nägin, mida nad koputavad seal.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd
Õpetaja: see on nüüd päriselt see sisu mis tuleb ja seda näitab praegult see. See on nii hästi nagu seal Jasonis Kõik Olemas näidised ja asjad
Õpetaja: päris süsteem ei tea, mis andmed sul on. Ma ütlen. Kujutage ette, et teil on kood. Teil on jaava kood Jaava Koodi pealt ee Genereeritakse niiöelda see dokumentatsioon, ega tema Ei tea, mis andmed on sul seal Tabelis? Tallinn Tartu pärnu.
Õpetaja: Tema teeb sulle niukse. Mudeli on Nüüd ma teen ta täpselt selliseks nagu meil pärast. Ta on,
Õpetaja: et esiteks, seal on ainult üks objekt on sees. Pole mõtet korrata seda.
Õpetaja: Nüüd City Id asemel on kaks
Õpetaja: seal, Näites, et Tallinna asemel on lihtsalt sõna String.
Õpetaja: Sest et see on mudel, See sisu ei ole meile siia koodi ära kirjutatud
Õpetaja: praegu, see On kindel see, et me loome. Ee, selle massiivi. Ja seal sees on üks objekt. Va väike väärtustega. Niuke, objekt on siin olemas, et See on olemas, aga ta oma tegelikku sisu saab niikuinii back endist. Sellest ma ütlen, et te võite si kõige lihtsamal viisil saaks võibolla väljendada, et siin on mingisugune massiiv.
Õpetaja: See endiselt töötab. See silt on endiselt olemas. Sa võid See on Javascript. Sa võid siia panna number Ühe Ka võid sa panna Üheksakümmend üheksa. Sa võid panna üheksakümmend üheksa. Neid teksti lihtsalt. No siis juba küll. Niimoodi Onju
Õpetaja: Sa võid siia Tegelikult, panna. Tegelikult. Ee. Mida iganes, sisuks oma tegelikku sisu. Ta saab. Selle get Cities meetodiga, Aga meil ei ole. Kasu
Õpetaja: sellisest olukorrast, kus Öeldakse, et see on mingi massiiv, sa tead,
Õpetaja: Siis me peame kuskil dokumentatsiooni minema vaatama, et siin koht, kus me paneme selle sisu siia, sisse. Sealt ei ole võimalik aru saada, et tuli sisse Niukene asi. Meil on vaja mudelit. Miks on see vee? Mudel
Õpetaja: seob databloki muutujad, Sest et tegelikult see on ju mudel.
Õpetaja: Enamus ajast tuleb sisu kuskilt mujalt.
Õpetaja: Kui mul on nihukene asi ees, siis ma juba saan aru, Citys on selline massiiv.
Õpetaja: Kus sees on? Palju objekte. Iga objekti sees on väärtus. Sitt on väljas. City Id ja City name,
Õpetaja: on nii Vot seda me tahame, aga kõige lihtsamal kujul. Niimoodi, Niimoodi me tahame siia saada.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd praegult Minul jälle võttis ta ära vaata need Jutumärgid kui võtnud. Tehke lõpp ja öelge Ungode Property. Names tuli niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Või on kaksik Nendega Vahet pole, teete siniseks ja ütlete Unquote Property names. Niimoodi peab olema sellepärast, et kui sa oled selle Jasonist Copy Based, siis ta võib teha selle vea.
Õpetaja: Nii see on mudel, kas See vastab su küsimusele, Hendrik.
Õpetaja: Et kõike ridu ei taha. Me ei kirjuta koodi sisse. Tallinntartupärnu, vaid need tulevad läbi api päringu, Back käimist.
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd ongi vaja seda teha.
Õpetaja: Hetkel tal ei ole mingit sisu. Ei usu. Palun väga tee lahti. Ee, veebi lehekülg. Mine pangaautomaadid lehele tee, inspekt. Noh, vaadake minu pealt, muidugi. Ah, jälle Ma tegin klikiga. No ei, jää. Meelde Ee, võtad siit see poetöriist
Õpetaja: Tuled otsivad ülesse selle komponendi.
Õpetaja: Vaata, Mcu klikid siia peale. Näed on Citys sees. Praegult. Üks objekt on
Õpetaja: hetkel sõnum. Isegi läheb teele ka. Sõnum läheb teele. Ma olen Refresh.
Õpetaja: Näed, sõnum Toob andmed ära. Aga see vastuse sisu. See respons, Data.
Õpetaja: Noh, kas siin ka näitab neid blokke või ei näita Response headers. Kahjuks ei näita Tatart. Siit näitab Tatat lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Et see sisu on olemas, aga me hetkel ei tee sellega midagi, Kui me nüüd tuleme siia sellesse meetodisse Respons, näed? Siin me nüüd istume. Nüüd. Siin ongi see plaan, et meil on vaja neid andmeid Ära salvestada, endale, et me saaksime nendega toimetada. Eelkõige
Õpetaja: siin siin üleval. Me tahame Drop Town I Teha nende andmete pealt
Õpetaja: siis, meil on vaja nad kuhugi panna. Kuhuga, millega nad on vaja panna siduda. Sellega, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii. No mis ma siis siin teen? Ma kirjutan
Õpetaja: Dispunkt Citys.
Õpetaja: Ma praegult näpuga katsun. Seda Citys objekti praegult selle koodireaga. Ma saaksin selle sisu kätte, kui ma tahaksin kuskile seda kuvada või mida iganes. Aga mina tahan uut sisu anda. Kuidas saab uut sisu anda?
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab Utsi suhelda võrdusmärgiga? Palun väga, nüüd paremale poole, Tuleb viidata Siis mingisugusele objektile või asjale.
Õpetaja: Ee, mi, mis, mis. Kas ma tahan lihtsalt öelda Noh, tekst? Näiteks kui ma tahan seda nii teha, ma Tahan, aga mina ei taha. Me tahame teha nüüd seda, mis see peint räägib meile.
Õpetaja: Kogu respons on meil kogu see objekt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd punkti kaudu saaks mõelda. Punkt, status, punkt, status, tekst, punkt. Data, mis mind huvitab?
Õpetaja: See ei huvitab punkt Data pomp. Siis ma ütlengi response näete Siin
Õpetaja: hävitub ainult siis, kui tuleb positiivne sõnum kahesajaga. Mingisugune status kakssada. Midagi
Õpetaja: Siin on väike sildikene ja siin on tegevus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd seda sildikest me Siin tegevuses kasutamegi. Me ütleme, et käivita abimeetod. Jälle See kohvimasin. Get Water. No siin on
Õpetaja: see. Objekt antakse kaasa. Siin on uus Sildikene See asi ei tea oma välisest elust ega tööd ega mütsi. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: ta ei tea, et ee on olemas niuke asi nagu respons. Siin on üks lihtsalt üks uus sildikene. Lihtsalt see sisu.
Õpetaja: See sisu seotakse selle muutujaga siin. Ütleme, et anna kaasa objekt. Objekti seatakse kaasa Siin on uus sildikene respons.
Õpetaja: Responsi? Me ütleme, et. Kuule, ole hea. Anna see respons This City Sele. Pane See, siia.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd Vaatame, oota, Mis teeb Pooleli.
Õpetaja: Ei jäänud ju pooleli. Siis on karjud.
Õpetaja: Ei ole midagi puudu.
Õpetaja: Ei ole Tata, T Ei, Ütle, Ma ütlen ju This viitabki data bloki muutujatele. Data on üldse meetod. Ta Pole väli, mida peale saab muuta, nagu viidata
Õpetaja: nii on nii lihtne see ongi. Anna uus. Aa, siin on puudu. Sorry, Data.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlesin, et sa mõtlesid kuidagi. Nii ma ei mäleta.
Õpetaja: Mõtlesin, et nii ikka. Onju, Ee, kui ma teen Refresh I. Nüüd ma saan vaadata Network ist.
Õpetaja: Läheb. Sõnum tuuakse respons ära.
Õpetaja: Aa, see võib olla nüüd Stoplight, kes Lihtsalt pani pange. Kõik vajasid Refresh i samal ajal.
Õpetaja: Ärge vajutage.
Õpetaja: Näe, Sain kätte response. Kui nüüd lähen vaatan Voest Atms View mitte on
Õpetaja: Kolm elementi on massiivis. Mis need siin on? Null üks, kaks.
Õpetaja: Need on elementide indeksid.
Õpetaja: Iga objekt selle massiivi Sees. On üks element. Ee Elementide indeksid arvavad numbrist Null, palun. Kes ei tea, millest ma räägin? Võtke tähtsamatest teemadest või otsige lihtsalt. Ee, seal kla. Selles
Õpetaja: siin ikka Ma panen ee. Ühe lingi juba panin. Teile. Panen teise ka. Kes Ei, tea, millest ma jäpin. Mis asi on ära ja siis, nagu Ee, palun tehke endale selgeks Tegelikult see on juba nendes listides olnud. Minu meelest, mida peaks õppima
Õpetaja: ära ja vaadatud. Kas tahab, Saab veel vaadata,
Õpetaja: Sest et siin räägitakse niukestest asjadest nagu elemendid. Kas ta on objekt Kas ta on String? Kas Ta on number? Vahet pole, Element. Element, element, element, element, element, element, Element
Õpetaja: Hakkavad indeksid nullist.
Õpetaja: Ja viimane indeks on siis üks vähem kui selle asja suurus üks, kaks, kolm, Neli, Mis on viimane indeks? Kolm, kolm. Klassikaline viga. Millega saab viga teha? On ju?
Õpetaja: Meil on siin indeksid.
Õpetaja: See on see asi nagu räägib kõik ära. Palun See video
Õpetaja: Can make it any better than that ausõna.
Õpetaja: No võtame siis selle lingi ka veel,
Õpetaja: Palun, Ee, viige end kurssi. Ma isegi ei vahita. Oli. Entrit Tuleb äkki juurde midagi.
Õpetaja: Nii kus me jäime? Ee, et meil on massiiv ja näed nad Siin on. See on element. Null element, üks
Õpetaja: Element Kaks on nii väga tore.
Õpetaja: Nii, Noh, teeme väikse alerdi siia. Lihtsalt Davai Alert, Ärge Teie tehke alert,
Õpetaja: kui mina tahaksin. Ee, vaatame korra neid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra neid andmeid siin. Ee, sees.
Õpetaja: Noh, mina.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame korra neid andmeid siin sees.
Õpetaja: Mina ütlen, missioon on Alerti. Lihtsalt Kuvada Tartu sõna. Tartu. Meil on siin kolm objekti Sees. Meie kirjutame niukse koodi, Mis lihtsalt kuvab sõna Tartu kasutades seda Cities objekti.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis ma siis kirjutan? Kust ma alustan?
Õpetaja: No praegult on mängumaa ikka väga lühike, Kus ma alustan? Nagu. Millega on mul üldse suhelda? Praegult? Noh, muidugi. This Cities. Siin on ju Need andmed, on ju praegu on ikka Väga, väga lihtne.
Õpetaja: Nii me nägime, et Tartu
Õpetaja: kus Tartu asub? Noh, ta läheb kogu aeg katki Jälle Ma korra siis panen niimoodi. Kus ta, kus Tartu asub?
Õpetaja: No, City name. No kohe, vaatame nüüd selle. Vaatame selle Ee, Poebloki poolt ja hakkame mõtlema, kui teie tahaksite viidata Cities, This City S. Ja järgmise asjana te ütlete näiteks punkt City Name.
Õpetaja: Siis mina vaataks, et kas sellel.
Õpetaja: Kas sellel objektil on väli City name ei ole,
Õpetaja: sest et ta ei olegi selles mõttes objekt ta on objekt ka, Aga ta on massiiv.
Õpetaja: Massiivil ei ole välja Massiivil on elemendil.
Õpetaja: Tal on element null.
Õpetaja: Tal on element üks ja tal on element kaks,
Õpetaja: aga tal ei ole välja Cityrain pole, on Nii, noh, okei.
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu. Alerdinan, mis? Mis siit tuleb, siis ta näitab, et on objekt, mille sees on objekt, Ma ei kujuta isegi ette. Mida ta näitab? Objekt, objekt. Objekt
Õpetaja: Palun väga praegu. Citys on sinna massiivina. Kolm objekti.
Õpetaja: Millist objekti? Meie tahame siit kätte, saada, Kas seda seda või seda
Õpetaja: keskmist, onju? Mis on selle indeks? Jah, see on niimoodi. Et näete, objekt määratakse praegult sinna massiiviobjekt nagu sulgudega, Kui Meie ütleks, Vaata,
Õpetaja: punkt City S kandilised sulud null, siis me saaksime selle objekti kätte. Ühega saaksime selle objekti kätte ja viimasega saaksime selle objekti kätte. Me vaatame, teeme Step by Step. Kui ma panen siia kandilised sulud ja. Ja nii on Meil ei ole mingeid elementi, Ma panen siia üks,
Õpetaja: siis. See on see keskmine.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd teen siin Refresh I,
Õpetaja: siis Ta peaks ütlema, et Kuule, palun väga Noh, et üks objekt on meil tore.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta ei oska objekti teisendada. Ma Praegu korra, teen onju? Ma ütlen, see kogu see alert on jama. Ma ütlen, Jason. Punkt Stringify.
Õpetaja: Ma panen korra selle objekti, et näita mulle seda objektist ringi. Kujul
Õpetaja: for the Love of Godsest Refresh.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta näitab, et siin sees jaavas kritiseeres on Objekt
Õpetaja: City Id Kolm City. Name, mida minul vaja on Tartut kätte saada.
Õpetaja: Jaa, Vot nüüd, kui ma tulen siia, võta nüüd tagasi
Õpetaja: Sest ring saab siia käia. Ma ütlen, et võta sealt element. Üks ehk siis teine Element punkt.
Õpetaja: Näete, miks ta pakub mulle praegult neid välja?
Õpetaja: Miks ta pakub neid välja? Mulle üldse siin, et Okei, sa tahad ilmselt midagi seda kirjutada,
Õpetaja: Sest me räägime Citys objektist. Ja tema struktuur on siin meil mudelina lahti kirjutatud.
Õpetaja: Kui ma kustutan selle ära kui ma tulen, Siia panen. Punkt
Õpetaja: ei paku enam, sest ta ei tea, Miuke see objekt välja näeb. Me pole ära defineerinud. Me tahame anda talle mudeli Veemodel kasutad neid asju interaktiivselt. Kasutad sõna mudel. See peaks juba kuidagi kõnetama. Siis
Õpetaja: Aga näe nüüd, ta juba pakub City name.
Õpetaja: No nüüd Las tuleb siis see tartu ära.
Õpetaja: Tartu Okei, see on siis massiiv. See meil nüüd on siin kenasti olemas, on nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, cool.
Õpetaja: Kas Meil on midagi muud teha, kui me saame need andmed kätte. Tegelikult mitte Selle Get City s missioon oligi saada City D.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui Tuleb mingi error Ja ärge mõelge. No kui me vaatame praegust vägerit, siis vägeri Erroritest midagi ei räägi et ta, räägib. Noh, ta räägib Tegelikult ta räägib, et kõik läheb. Hästi
Õpetaja: ja ta ütleb internal Server. Error Midagi ei läheks totaalselt.
Õpetaja: Siis saad viissada.
Õpetaja: Midagi Ei, läks serveris endas katki. See tähendab, et midagi ikkagi võib minna halvasti Juhul,
Õpetaja: kui tuleb mingisugune error, siis me kukume siia blokki
Õpetaja: ja jällegi, see et Me saame teha seal Süntaksi ette. Kontroll, tühik.
Õpetaja: Catch Reason. Minule ei meeldi. Mulle meeldib, et ta ütleb Error
Õpetaja: nii eelmine kord me pidime vaatama, et kui on staatus nelisada kolm ja error kood on üks, üks siis nagu kuva alerti üle Hetkel meil niukest mingi niukest tingimust pole, onju? Pole mingit custom error eit.
Õpetaja: Minu Küsimus on siis, kui me teame, et mingi viga tuleb, aga see pole meie viga, siis Noh, me programmeerida nagu ei saa, ära, aga kasutajale peab küll kuidagi nagu ka märku andma, et et midagi on totaalselt kaputt mis me Tahame siis teha
Õpetaja: see error. I error on.
Õpetaja: Me peame siin ehitama.
Õpetaja: Jah, mis me tahame teha?
Õpetaja: Me tahame kasutajale, mida me tahame. Öelge Lihtsalt lihtlabaselt. Ärme räägi veel koodist, mis me tahame teha,
Õpetaja: kui kui midagi läheb totaalselt katki. Me Kasutaja peab siin saama nagu valida rippmenüüst linnasi ja näha mingeid andmeid. Aga rippmenüüs andmeid ei saa. No mis me siis ütleme? Noh, me. Me. Kuidas me nüüd selle programmi lihtsalt Ära lahendame, mis me tahame. Mis siis juhtuma peaks? Vähemalt kasutaja vaates.
Õpetaja: Mis info ilmub?
Õpetaja: Õige õigel tööl oled.
Õpetaja: Aga mis see info on? Sa võid, sest, et see Error saab olla mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa öelda. Mis Error see on? See pole meie enda programmeeritud error Nagu vale Kasutaja. Nimi või parool. Siin on seda, et midagi läks vist täitsa tuksi.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis? See info on, mis me tahame kasutajale öelda.
Õpetaja: Näidata.
Õpetaja: Mm ups. Midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Kas meil on juba tehtud visuaalne pool, ära, mis ütleb. Ja tuumaplahvatus. Ja kõik asjad, Me teame et Meie programmis on see vaade. Lihtsalt, onju
Õpetaja: Nüüd see tähendab seda, et me praegult oleme praegu.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me peame suunama kasutaja, kuhu Error View sse.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me seda teeme? Meil oli mingi oma süsteem ja tööriistad ka juba tehtud. Veits valmis,
Õpetaja: et seda koodi ennast me ei hakka kirjutama Iga kord muidugi. Mis selle meetodi nimi on ja kus ta elab?
Õpetaja: Vaata Error Use ja meetodi nimi peaks olema.
Õpetaja: Ei Ole error. Error View on visuaal Ahah, No Räägi Margariita.
Õpetaja: No räägi sina siis edasi.
Õpetaja: Mis see ei olnud,
Õpetaja: Navigation. Jälle on meil midagi, Vaatame korra, tõmbame sors I kokku. On meil navigation,
Õpetaja: On ju nagu sinna mingi help. Nagu nüüd on Navigation Service. Me oleme siia ära juba progenud. Need koodiread. Mine Atms vaatesse. Mine error ruuti. Mine, Aga me ei taha neid koodiridu uuesti uuesti kirjutada,
Õpetaja: et me tahame öelda Hello wifi to something
Õpetaja: and do exactly this, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, siis siin on okei see muuta ja ignoreerimine praegu, teda, mis see tegevus, On mis? Mis tahame teha, Mis ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: No kui ma kirjutan navigate,
Õpetaja: ei ole midagi vaja. Vaadata. Mõelge lihtsalt praegu. Mina tahan viidata mingile meetodile, mis justkui oleks. Siin. No siis peaks risk käes olema. Ta ei ole siin
Õpetaja: punkti.
Õpetaja: Mm, me tahame käivitada seda koodirida, Mis elab selles meetodis
Õpetaja: Bingo, me peame viitama kõigepealt sellele skriptifailile. Kus see meetod asub?
Õpetaja: See on see Wifi Service Siin on Navigation Service Ns
Õpetaja: tuleb. Siin on nii vähe asju praegu. Navigation Service Import tuli ülesse. Näete? Jah,
Õpetaja: see on nüüd see nagu Their Wifi. Aa, täpselt Samamoodi nagu see. Too mulle andmeid. Siin on nagu midagi muud. Vaata, on ju, et see see tegevus on kellegile suunatud subjekt ja tema sees. Tema oskab neid tegevusi käivitada. Kui sa ütled õiged sõnad.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd on kõik väga hästi, aga nüüd ütleb, et ja aga saab Põhimõtteliselt mingid andmed. Sul on mingi sildikene selle jaoks, mis püüab panna nüüd ta sisse.
Õpetaja: Aga sa ei tee sellega midagi.
Õpetaja: Nad on hall Ja meil ei olegi seekord midagi teha. Mis iganes seal info error i sees on, Seal ei ole mitte midagi, mis? Mitte kuidagigi aitaks See on nii geneeriline, et lihtsalt see. See viga ongi. Error. Kogu informatsioon ongi selline.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole seda, vaja
Õpetaja: aga nüüd on niimoodi, et see süntaks vajab siis nagu toimimiseks teatud viise, et et. Okei, seekord käivitan mingit tegevust, aga see vastus mis siia Catch bloki kukub, Seda me ei seo millegagi.
Õpetaja: Kui te panete Sellised tühjad sulud, on nagu see, et vaadake, siin üleval on response ja sulgude sees
Õpetaja: tehniliselt Võttes ta töötab ilma sulgudeta ka väga hästi.
Õpetaja: Aga võib ka olla nagu. Ma ei tea, kuidas sinna tekkisid lasteas olla, seekord meil lihtsalt ei ole siin sulgude sees mingisugust errorit. Sest et temaga ei ole midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Siis see süntaks on selline. See on nagu anonüümne käivitamine,
Õpetaja: et me see asi teeb lihtsalt seda, et. Et peale seda käivitub mingi tegevus.
Õpetaja: Aga seekord meil ei ole mingisuguseid sildikesi, mida me sooviksime siin kasutada. Vaata, meil ei ole vaja midagi.
Õpetaja: Anonüümne käivitus.
Õpetaja: Kui siin oleks mitu tegevust? Mitu erinevat errorit, siis me peaks tegema eraldi meetodi, Vaatame, mis sealt sisse tuli. Kas tuli mingi viga, Mis me teame, et võib? Noh, programmiliselt tulla. Ja nüüd me mõtleme, kuidas front reageerib Nagu nendele Erroritele. Mäletate? See error. Kood üks, üks,
Õpetaja: see, üks, üks error. Kood on lihtsalt nagu kokku lepitud error. Kood, mis tähendab vale Kasutaja nimi ka Borool.
Õpetaja: Seal Me programmeerisime ära, et kui tuleb Nihukene olukord, üks üks meie jaoks. Error kood, siis meie Frontist. Tahame kuvada Seda sisu, mis sealt tuli,
Õpetaja: et igast erinevaid erroreid võib olla. Ja meie saame siis kasutada neid kokku lepitud koode või staatuseid, Mis iganes, Vaata, et siis programmeerida oma süsteem,
Õpetaja: et mis tema peab tegema. Aga hetkel on lihtsalt niukene, et midagi läks totaalselt tuksi.
Õpetaja: Siin Me programmeerime ka ära. Mis me tahame teha. Siis me suudame kasutada sellele vaatele, et uks midagi oleks vaest, et
Õpetaja: tema vähemalt saab aru, et noh, katki on.
Õpetaja: Ta ei saagi rohkem teada kui katki.
Õpetaja: Aga meil ei ole ka rohkemat infot. Meil ei ole mitte midagi muud Talle öelda.
Õpetaja: Meil endal ka ei ole mingit infot. See ei ole nelisada. Kolm ja error, kood, üks, üks, see Ei, ole see Case, on ju?
Õpetaja: See ei ole meie programmeeritud viga. See pole midagi, mida me oleme nagu spek is ära maininud, et ei. Kui sa käivitad sellise teenuse, Kui me korra vaatame neid. Me vaatame korra neid teisi teenuseid siin pulli pärast, nagu.
Õpetaja: Noh, Put I postiga. Vaatame näiteks uue pangaautomaadi asukoha Lisamine,
Õpetaja: mis siin võib tulla Kakssada see on, kui kõik läheb hästi. Aga ta mingit ee, keha vastu ei anna. Ütleb nelisada. Kolm For Bidden
Õpetaja: Sellise nimega pangaautomaadi asukoht on juba süsteemis olemas. Kolm, kolm, nüüd, meie Frontist. Kui me. Hakkame lisama uut pangaautomaati, siis me saame otsustada. Et. Oot, oot, mis me nüüd siis kasutajale tahame? Nagu öelda. Vaata. Noh, Näitame talle korra, et See nimi, mis sa üritad täita, vaata, et see on juba olemas. Süsteemis Kaht korda ei saa, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, aga igal asjal igal igal sellel teenusel, üks asi on, mis tuleb Lihtsalt vaikimisi.
Õpetaja: Ee, rror Viissada internal server. Error
Õpetaja: back end is on mingi viga.
Õpetaja: Ee, enam see ee. Programm ei oska meile mingisugust programmeeritud vastust anda, vaid ütleb midagi. Oleks katki. Programmeerimisviga Andmebaasis on midagi. Valesti kuidagi. Mis see põhjused võib olla väga palju erinevaid, mis iganes võib katki minna.
Õpetaja: Aga mida ta peab vastama? Ja kui see meie back end is, lähebki midagi nagu katki. Vaata, kuskil on. Mida iganes kuskil katki, siis ta lihtsalt vastab vaikimisi. Midagi läks valesti. See on tema versioon sellest. Ups, midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Nii Okei, nüüd finali. Ee, nüüd Ongi täpselt see teema, Vaata, et. Aga tegelikult meil ju peaks olema.
Õpetaja: Meil peaks olema ka mingisugune see.
Õpetaja: Kurat, ma ei tea, kuidas seda. Siin teha on kahe sõnumiga
Õpetaja: abi küsima. Jätame selle finali hetkel niimoodi siia rippuma, et ta on silme ees, aga ta on ka enne Nagu to do.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen seda Spinnerit.
Õpetaja: Tegeleme selle päris ee asjaga praegult edasi. See teine on niuke tilulilu.
Õpetaja: No nüüd, meil on need andmed olemas. Me nägime, need on olemas ja kui midagi läheb väga katki, siis ta läheb ka siin. Ups, midagi läheks valesti. Nüüd on küsimus, et siis mis edasi?
Õpetaja: No taas tegelikult isegi ütleb siis mis? Edasi,
Õpetaja: Aa, kõik linnad. Tropdown is on selline valik, mida saab valida. Kas see valik ei tule Jasonist? Tehniliselt võttes meil on see Staff olemas. Siin
Õpetaja: kõik linnad. Nüüd Praegult on niimoodi meil selles rippmenüüs on. Need täpselt need kolm valikut on To free.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis meil on vaja aru saada, on see, et kui meil on mingi mall, ees,
Õpetaja: et milline on? Esiteks see element,
Õpetaja: mida? Mis Mis Alates mida me. Mida me soovime dünaamiliselt mingi massiivi pealt kokku panna,
Õpetaja: et milline on tegelikult see element, mida me peame hakkama dünaamiliselt ehitama.
Õpetaja: No mis te arvate, mis reast ma võin rääkida?
Õpetaja: Kümme? Kümme. On? Kogu see lekboks
Õpetaja: Seda me dünaamiliselt selles mõttes ei tee, et et see ei tule. Meil Näiteks kolm tükki.
Õpetaja: Kolmteist on juba õige. Seda me tahame niikuinii Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Ja põhimõtteliselt nüüd ütleme, et alates sellest reast alates soovime me neid kordusi Iks arv korda. Kui me kustutame need ära, paneme Esialgu küsimärgi siia
Õpetaja: küsimärgi, siis vastavalt sellele, kui palju meil seal neid linnu on? Ma panen näiteks. Kas kui niimoodi
Õpetaja: siis nii palju peab siia Option eid tulema on nii.
Õpetaja: Ja me teame, et nagu see, asi, see element peab dünaamiliselt tulema
Õpetaja: automaatselt andmete ehk selle objekti pealt Vot nii
Õpetaja: nii okei. Kui see on meil nüüd selgeks tehtud, siis need ülejäänud võib seda ära kustutada, on ju? Küsimus on nüüd see, vaata. Et. Noh,
Õpetaja: et, ee, et mis see nüüd sisu ka siin on, on ju. Ja kui palju neid tuleb?
Õpetaja: Nii Ee, link Loops With Collection. On keegi seda materjali ise näinud?
Õpetaja: Kes ei ole Kahju, et ma ei jõudnud teile eile, öelda, et vaadake täna ära, ma Tegelt veits. Mäletasin seda, aga mõtlesin, et savi vaatame koos niikuinii, sest keegi on ikka, kes ei vaata ja siis, noh, midagi ei ole, teha, et kõik kaasa saaksid käia
Õpetaja: Siin kõige parem on vaadata minu tehtud video
Õpetaja: Ee, kõik eestikeelsed videod on tegelt kunagi valid inimestele lihtsalt tehtud
Õpetaja: ja siia. Ee Niiöelda meie ekursusse veel juurde pandud. Kõik on muidu Inglis keeles ja järsku on Eesti keeles.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis Rain räägib meile.
Õpetaja: Me oleme käima. Kes Pole seda näinud Suuremaks Kohe
Õpetaja: kui seda lähme, vaatame korra Youtube S. Seda seal saab kvaliteeti igavesti. Tõsta, mulle Tundus see kuidagi nägune.
Õpetaja: Oot, oot, äpi. Äpi, äpi.
Õpetaja: Paneme ikka neli. K Tundub siin. Ee, le Korraliku interneti arve.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nii, okei, ta Räägib edasi. Vaatame lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Oot, oot, oot, Üks asi veel. Normal speed. Ee, üks koma viis.
Õpetaja: Noh, näete, mis ei ole mingi list, onju
Õpetaja: Kui oleks üks bukotar objekt, siis lihtsalt olekski. Bookotar on List on mitmuses. Noh,
Õpetaja: ja vaata, isegi ei niimoodi markeerib parem veelkord animatsioonid,
Õpetaja: see On Muutuja loomine, tüüp muutuja. See on sildikene Bukotar on Ainsuses.
Õpetaja: Siin on viide sellele objektile, mis on seal üleval Okei,
Õpetaja: me seome nüüd Objekti muutuja nimega.
Õpetaja: See on sild. See ei ole objekt.
Õpetaja: See on silt, mis on seotud selle objektiga.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil see Robert Martini Objekt objektil on meetod, mis võtab nagu mingi täisnime. Mis iganes
Õpetaja: sellelt objektilt käivitatakse meetod, get out. Orienteeritud programmeerimine prüünnitakse. Lihtsalt. Konsooli on ju No midagi erilist ei toimu
Õpetaja: Kirjutad koodi ühe kohaga? Ei tea, palju sul seal massiivis objekte on? Vahet pole viisteist. Ta käib nüüd ükshaaval kõik läbi. Iga kord, mis ta teeb. Ta võtab ühe objekti. Ta seob selle muutuja nimega Selleks. Tsükliks
Õpetaja: teeb kõik läbi, kui sul on kümme Rida koodi ta. Teeb selle kümme rida koodi läbi kui sul. On üks rida kood ja ta käib üks rida kood läbi. Vahet pole. Iga objektiga käib läbi. On küsimusi Kellegil selle kohta
Õpetaja: ei ole. Okei, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Ta nüüd hakkab konsolis jooksutama ja me näeme, et Need nimed tulevad siia ülesse. Vaata, et see on nüüd ema. Ei oma nagu enam rolli, mida meie nüüd tahame teha? Täpselt samamoodi
Õpetaja: täpi pealt. Samamoodi nagu dünaamiliselt käiakse. Lihtsalt Kood käib ise tsüklitega läbi. Ja siis toimetab ja tegutseb. Meie. Nüüd tahame teha sellest see üks option.
Õpetaja: Mis meil seal on praegu ära markeeritud. Ütleme, et. Hei, võta sina see Html Element. Ja nüüd, mis juhtub, on see et sina ehita neid elemente Täpselt nii palju, kui siin on neid selles massiivis objekte igal tsüklil. Lihtsalt loo Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: behind aseens. Üks uus objekt sellest asjast Kus ees. Me hakkame tegema tsüklit? Nii, pange tähele ma seda süsteemi natukene. Ma korra panen tagasi. Kus on need tüübid ja asjad?
Õpetaja: Kollektsioon on Siin paremal.
Õpetaja: Üksik Muutuja on siin vasakul.
Õpetaja: See asi jääb meil nüüd sarnaseks samasuguseks.
Õpetaja: Ainukene vahe, mis on on see, et jaavas me tüüpi. Me ei määra sildi juurde.
Õpetaja: Noh, saab nagu lett ja see. Vaata, seda pole vaja. Ei, ei ole Ja selle
Õpetaja: selle kooloni asemel on sõna in kollektsioon. Muutuja, Muutuja in kollektsioon.
Õpetaja: Hakkame seda sama staffi tegema.
Õpetaja: Nii Teeme nüüd koodibaasi lahti.
Õpetaja: Tee. Me Oleme välja selgitanud, mis on see dünaamiline element, mida me soovime niiöelda siis teha? Nii, mit, nagu põhimõtteliselt. Dünaamiliselt luua selle objekti pealt,
Õpetaja: siis kuidas see käib, on See, et esiteks Me saime aru, See on. See on see,
Õpetaja: see, on. See See on hästi, selge? Nüansson, see.
Õpetaja: Noh, kus sa oled, Mine, see on see.
Õpetaja: Me oleme selgitanud välja selle dünaamilise osa ära. Kas on mingi div
Õpetaja: või? See on otse mingi element. Vahet pole seda asja, mis on selles skoobis. Kui ma paneks siia selle Four tsükli,
Õpetaja: siis tekiks neid Selectbox E nii palju, kui on tsükleid,
Õpetaja: kui Siin on mingi div. Näiteks kolum. Ma teen siia selle tsükli sisse. Siis kogu see kood. Mis on
Õpetaja: siis tuleb kolumneid. Nii, mitu Igas Ühe sees on üks
Õpetaja: Select. Saate aru? No ma teen lihtsalt sellest Dublikaadi. No kujutage ette. Noh,
Õpetaja: noh, te peate aru saama, et kuhu Ma tahan teha oma Fourchycklit. Siin on meie vastus. Kuidas teha. For checklit on niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Mis täht ma siia kirjutan? Esimene täht veel, mitte V Sidekriips.
Õpetaja: Voor
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kuidas mäletad? Nagu kuidas süntaks? Kuidas seda asja teid nagu valmis ehitada, on niimoodi, et teeme esialgu niukse hästi väikse Templeti
Õpetaja: muutuja in kollektsioon ja lihtsamad küsimärk. In Küsimärk.
Õpetaja: Kas te suudate niukse asja pähe õppida?
Õpetaja: Küsimärk on küsimärk, sest et me tahame teha Paremat poolt
Õpetaja: vasakut poolt ja ülejäänud asjad loksuvad ise siis juba pa paika.
Õpetaja: Mis on paremal poolel paremal poolel. On, No mis? On paremal poolel.
Õpetaja: Kollektsioon.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meil siin selles programmis Sellel ajahetkel, mis on meie kollektsioon?
Õpetaja: Mitte City vaid City Cities. Okei,
Õpetaja: kui hakkame kirjutama siia C tähega, siis vaatame, mis juhtub. Noh, ta natuke laegab mul siin, niimoodi. Aga
Õpetaja: Kas pakub juba Cities?
Õpetaja: Nüüd me peame ise välja mõtlema mingi sildikese, mis on siin pool.
Õpetaja: Ja kui siin on mingi kollektsioon ja siin on üksik indiviid, siis on väga lihtne see on mis iganes on selle asja nimi. Ainult et
Õpetaja: ainsuses ja ongi kõik. See tuleb siis City.
Õpetaja: Nii pim, põmm, pim, põmm.
Õpetaja: Kui Juba nüüd minna, mees, Sest et mis Hästi, et ta alla joonib,
Õpetaja: mis? Sest et ta alla joonib,
Õpetaja: võiks juba midagi nagu olla, Talle ei meeldi Ee, mis Seal täpselt on, Aga midagi võiks siin. Olla.
Õpetaja: Mis siin on, Mis Te panete tähele? Mis siin on üks, kaks, kolm on nii.
Õpetaja: Siin On ju ainult üks rida. Ju? Kõik linnade all. Meil on kokku neli onju? Kõik linnad, Üks, kaks, kolm. Ta juba teeb seda, mida ta peab tegema.
Õpetaja: Ta teeb vastavalt andmetele veefooriga. Nii mitu seda Htm elementi, mille sees me oleme?
Õpetaja: Siin on lihtsalt küsimärgid. Kui ma panen siia. Aa, siis meil on siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, kohe tuleb ülejäänud ka. Aa on nii?
Õpetaja: Korraks näitas ühte, sest et ta laadis ära kõigepealt selle lehe. Kus on üks objekt,
Õpetaja: Siis läks päring teele ja järsku see muutus.
Õpetaja: Vaata, kui hästi korraks vaadata ja viiega.
Õpetaja: No hästi korraks, nagu On näha, et nagu laeb.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tema reageerib nendele andmetele.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Step by step, Aga meie ei, taha, et on Aa,
Õpetaja: mida meie tahame, Et oleks seal nähtav osa, mis? Mis peaks olema City name, onju?
Õpetaja: Nimelt
Õpetaja: siis nüüd meie mängumaa. Hetkel on kõik muutuvad. Mis on siin, Mis Vahet pole, mis on, aga meil on nüüd üks sildikene juurde tekkinud
Õpetaja: City.
Õpetaja: See nüüd tähistab ühte objekti. See on Eno raud hetkel, mis Iganes esimesel tsüklil mõttes.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on siin City.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd uus sildikene.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Mina tahaks siia selle küsimärkide asemel hoopis, et Tuleks
Õpetaja: siis konkreetse Niiöelda linna nimi. Siis ma küsin, mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Cityname vä. See name.
Õpetaja: Mm, ma ei tea kuidagi saan. Seda Ma ei tea, kirjutan eksole?
Õpetaja: Aga miks peakski?
Õpetaja: Miks peakski? See on ju lihtsalt teksti. Vaata, ma ju ei viitanud ühelegi muutujale ega millelegi Lihtsalt teksti.
Õpetaja: A, mine. Mina just ütlesin vihjeks. Vaata, et meil on üks uus muutaja mängus, et meil on. Meil on alati ligipääs absoluutselt Kõigele, mis on siin tatablokis user Idys meil on. Noh, see Citysel samal realgi kasutatud. Aga nüüd ma ütlen, et meil on üks uus Sildike veel juures, Mille taga on objekt,
Õpetaja: Siis mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: No me just proovisime. City name. Kas ma teen seda uuesti?
Õpetaja: Kuidas Te kuidas teil ei kliki ära?
Õpetaja: Kaugelt, väga hea. Topelt Loogiliselt sulle, et. Okei, poolel teel. Mis nüüd?
Õpetaja: No keegi ütles juba Cityrame vä, et siin on mingi muutuja City name.
Õpetaja: Kiitos.
Õpetaja: Citynam ei tule. Viitab, et ütleb, et niukest muutujat ei ole olemas, kuna nüüd ma olen andnud märku. Vaata, et ma võtan muutujast.
Õpetaja: Tema ütleb, et Citynay. Ma võin niukest muuta, et ei ole kuskil nada.
Õpetaja: Pole ei siin
Õpetaja: ega Ole ka siin, aga. No nüüd ta juba peaks teadma, mis õige vastus on. Juba tuleb neid vastuseid ka.
Õpetaja: See ongi ju meie. See Objekt ühel tsüklil sööme, ei muutu. Ja kui sa kirjutad, siia City
Õpetaja: mu meelega veel Näed, kas see koer on muutunud ka? Vaata, Kas See on valge,
Õpetaja: See on valge Joont. Alla ei tõmba. No vaata mis ta siia sisse paneb. Praegu kogu
Õpetaja: objekti paneb teeb streng Iks City Id. Kaks City Name City Id kaks.
Õpetaja: Jah, siit võib ütleda, et Kuule, selle ühe objekti sees. Ja nüüd on jälle. Kuidas ta teab, et on siin niuksed väljad,
Õpetaja: sest et me oleme ära defineerinud. Selle mudeli
Õpetaja: meil on massiiv. Muidu ei saaks for loopida teha. Ta Läheks hulluks, Lihtsalt kui on mingi tavaline asi.
Õpetaja: Siin on objektid ja siin sees on niuksed väljad. Ja jällegi vaata, see, mis me siin kirja paneme, Peab nüüd kokku langema sellega. Vaata, mida me päriselt saame.
Õpetaja: Et kui sa tegelikult ikka tulevad mingid muud väljanimed, siis ei tule Seda sisu kunagi ei tohi ära unustada. Sa võid sinu mudelisse defineerida. Mida iganes ülisavi, mis seal tegelikult taga on. Tuleb Meil objektist, tuleb Javascripti objekt, sest andmed tulevad meil andmebaasist.
Õpetaja: Jasonist. Jason tehakse objektiks. Mis seal tegelikult sees on? See seal tegelikult sees on see, mis sa Siia mudelisse kirjutad? Kirjuta, mida iganes. No näitame ka, mis viga tuleb Ütleme, et siin on. Ma Panen mitmusesse. Mingil põhjusel
Õpetaja: teeme. Oota, teeme Kõrvalt reegelt. Vaata, onju, Ma panen ära. Vaata, Näed,
Õpetaja: kui sa kirjutad siia City name ja lähme vaatame tulemust.
Õpetaja: Tallinn Tartu Pärnu on
Õpetaja: kui Mina mudelis on viga. Panen mingi põhjuse mitmusesse. Noh, siin Kutsun õigesti välja. Koodi mõttes. Kõik on tip Top on ju Tal ei ole Tegelt mingit biifi. Aga siin on nagu tühjus. Miks,
Õpetaja: sest, et seal ei ole objektis niukest asja nagu City Names vaid on City name,
Õpetaja: et siin on see asi, mida te ei tohi programmiliselt Frontist võib tunduda kõik üli Timm Ja vaatad ei ole
Õpetaja: tegelikult päeva lõpuks on seal selline objekt taga, mis tuleb Back endist läbi
Õpetaja: kaks erinevat asja et siin on see asi. Kui te teete mingisuguseid muudatusi nende objektidega, mis saadetakse süsteemist välja sõnumitena.
Õpetaja: Siis te peate arvestama seda, et
Õpetaja: ega automaagiliselt front korda ei lähe või need on juba kasutatud, tuleb. Seal ka parandused teha. Ja see on tavaline. See on okei, kui nimed muutuvad, see on okei. Kui asju tehakse ilusamaks paremaks kui tuleb mingit infot juurde, siis te peate ise mõtlema seda, et te peate siin ka need asjad korda tegema.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui ta ikkagi on ikkagi Cityname siis ta peab siin olema. City Name ka, Sest et vastasel juhul asjad lihtsalt
Õpetaja: ei toimi korrektselt.
Õpetaja: Päriselt tuleb Back endist just selline Sisu, kus on? Noh, sa oled ju teinud
Õpetaja: kindlust. Võiks tulla
Õpetaja: Küsimusi.
Õpetaja: Okei. Ee, nüüd siin on üks asi on veel meil on praegult Üsna lihtne. Aa, asi. Meil ei ole isegi tabel tabelis. Võibolla väga palju andmeid.
Õpetaja: Ehk. Siis see objekt massiiviga võib olla niimoodi, et et Objektis ei ole lihtsalt kaks välja, vaid Neid on terve posu.
Õpetaja: Tabelis. Soovid ju rohkem asju näidata, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on niimoodi, et see süsteem ise. Tegelikult. Nüüd peab ju jälgima seda, et kui toimub siin selles City sees päriselt andmete vahetusi, siis tuleb Html kood ju uuesti Joonistada ja renderdada
Õpetaja: Uuesti tuleb genereerida, et näed kolm optionit tuleb.
Õpetaja: Tema jälgib muutusi objektides.
Õpetaja: Need on reaktiivsed muutujad. Selles mõttes, et Voe ise jälgib muutusi.
Õpetaja: Kui järsku tuleb ikka, et siin on ainult kaks linna
Õpetaja: Järsku sa saad neli linna, siis ta teab, et ta peab uuesti renderdama sellest veebilehest. Konkreetse osa
Õpetaja: peab uuesti nagu tegema Html koodi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi. Ta suudab arutada neid objekte siin sees enamvähem jälgida, kas on muudatus või mitte, aga
Õpetaja: tal vahel tekib väikseid vigu ja tõrkeid, et ta tegelikult ei saa aru, et ta taustal on toimunud mingi Väikene muudatus.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd kui me teeme voortsükli, siis on selline süsteem, et, ee, me tahame anda voele jälgimiseks ainult ühe pisikese osa sellest objektist
Õpetaja: ühe pisikese osa enda objektist, mida ta peab jälgima. Kas on muudatust või mitte? Saate aru Massiivselt sada elementi ka alla tuhat ka
Õpetaja: proovi jälgida kõike tervikuna.
Õpetaja: Siis on niimoodi, et on kokku lepitud selline atribuut nagu Key ehk võti.
Õpetaja: Ja siis saab olla meil niimoodi, et me Saame ise anda ette talle ee, mingisuguse soovita soovitavat unikaalse väärtuse, midagi mis on unikaalne, igas objektis võimalikult lihtne, lihtsad andmed, mida tema peab jälgima ja ta jälgib, et kui muutuvad need andmed,
Õpetaja: siis ta teab, et ta on aeg uuesti joonistada. Kujutage ette, tabeli puhul võib olla Vrg kasvõmmend viis
Õpetaja: ja võibki olla kakskümmend viis. Välja. Näiteks mis mitte
Õpetaja: ta ei. Tal on raskusi vaadata seda asja tervikuna,
Õpetaja: aga kui Iga rea peal on üks unikaalne Mingisugune väärtus, mida peab järgima.
Õpetaja: Siis Tema saab teha endale väikse niukse listi taustal ja ta jälgib ainult neid asju
Õpetaja: ja siis ta saab vaadata, kas on toimunud muudatus või mitte.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on. Mida on lihtsamad On need unikaalsed andmed, Ma Mõtlen seda, et on vahe. Kas on tekst
Õpetaja: Ja see on number? Näiteks
Õpetaja: Numbrit On palju kiirem üles vaadata, kas on või ei ole tekstis. Sa pead igat tähemärki võrdlema. Eraldi
Õpetaja: nagu valikute vastu programmiliselt.
Õpetaja: Ma küsin, nagu. Mis te arvate, mis võiks olla konkreetselt selle objekti puhul
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla nagu see väli, mida ta peaks jälgima?
Õpetaja: Id, See on täiesti perfect. Sa mängid nii hästi kokku relatsioonilise andmebaasiga. Need on kordumatult erinevad.
Õpetaja: Kui mina annan talle. Kas kui tuhat objekti ja siis ei kujutage ette, on mingit. Välju veel mingid erinevad asjad
Õpetaja: pilt ja Mida Jumal teab, mis see kõik võiks, olla, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kui mina annan talle nagu. Et. Kuule, ole nüüd, pai poiss. Vaata, onju? Lihtsalt jälgi. Vaata seda. City Id D. Võta need väärtused. Ja kui ühel hetkel sa näed, et ee, need niiöelda. Seal taustal muutuvad City Id väärtused. Kas ka üks nendest? Siis Sa tead, et sa pead selle kogu asja joonistama uuesti.
Õpetaja: Noh, selle osa nüüd see punane joon siin Hetkel ongi nagu see. Vaata, bla, bla, bla, Ta räägib sellest.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin, mis lõpeb siin ära.
Õpetaja: Me peame siia tekitama juurde atribuudi nimega.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me peame talle andma mingisuguse väärtuse.
Õpetaja: No, me just rääkisime, mis? Mis me tahame.
Õpetaja: Kust see väärtus peaks tulema, et mida Ta peaks iga objekti puhul jälgima, mida ta peab. Räägime
Õpetaja: City Id. Nüüd öelge teie palun mulle. Mina olen täiesti uus arendaja. Palun aidake, Vend, mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Mis ma siin nüüd teen? Mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Idee või viis?
Õpetaja: Aa, Aa Citys
Õpetaja: Punkt City, Id City S on objekt. Aga kas ta on tavaline objekt või? Ta on massiiv
Õpetaja: kui mi praegult. Kui oleks, Ma teen korra siia City S juurde Nagu samamoodi. Vaadake, kui ta oleks objekt,
Õpetaja: siis tal oleks Väljad City Id ja nii edasi aitab. City null.
Õpetaja: Siis saaks rääkida. Näiteks et Kui mina tahaksin saada, ma ei tea kõikidele linnadele mingi City Id. Siis ma ütleks Cities. Punkt City Id
Õpetaja: on ju, kui see oleks objekt,
Õpetaja: aga see ei ole. Esiteks, objekt.
Õpetaja: See on ju massiiv.
Õpetaja: Siin On elemendid. Mina saan öelda Citys. Anna mulle Indeksil null
Õpetaja: objekte sealt Seest City Id. Aga ma ei saaks mitte kunagi öelda Citys punkt City Id. Sellepärast, et siin objektis ei ole niukest välja nimega City Id
Õpetaja: siin. On elemendid. Objektidest.
Õpetaja: Citysega ei ole midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, me peame ju jälgima. Noh, võtame siis selle.
Õpetaja: Me peame jälgima neid väärtusi Individuaalselt seda.
Õpetaja: Seda Seda aga igal tsüklil? Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: igal tsüklil ju. Kas vastab tõele, et kui mina panen siia Cityname siis tuleb ju erinevate Linnade nimed siit tulevad.
Õpetaja: Siin taga on tegelikult City Id.
Õpetaja: Siin taga on ka City Id. Ja siin pärnu taga on ka City Id.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt praegu. Me ei kuva neid kuidagi välja. Aga need on olemas seal
Õpetaja: Ja see ongi see võti, mis siia peab käima,
Õpetaja: Siis ma Küsin nüüd uuesti, mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: City Id ei kirjuta Selle Me juba stabilisime. Ka ei kirjuta Citys Punkt City Id
Õpetaja: pooleli No ma Võin pärnu loogilised suled, Aga ma ütlen. No, ühe tegi paari vist ei teinud.
Õpetaja: On see?
Õpetaja: Ei, okei, parem parem parem. Aga vaata, See Ei ole Ainukene City Punkt City
Õpetaja: Id. Viitame sellele objektile samamoodi nagu me viitasime siin.
Õpetaja: Ja tahaks lihtsalt City name i asemel Seal City Id D võiks nii olla.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle sama asja korra.
Õpetaja: Ee, las ma vaatan korra. Kuidas me seda saaks teha.
Õpetaja: Millise Mis värvi See tekst ta on.
Õpetaja: Teeme. Teeme siin kanda. Roheliseks.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei ole. Ei, ei, las olla niimoodi. Las oleks niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Teeme nüüd inspectuli lahti, Natuke teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Ma tulen klikin sõna otseses mõttes. Selle peale
Õpetaja: vajutan inspekt ja ta teeb element Vaate lahti mul Kohe automaatselt ja no selle elemendi peal, mida ma just klikkisin.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on Select See sama koodina. Ma teen nüüd ta lahti, et saame kõik opsioneid näha, on, Nii,
Õpetaja: Oota korra. Ee, Ah kurat, Ghid ei saa vaadata, aga. Okei, ma teen teistmoodi. Ma panen korraks ta siia. Vaata näete seda küsimärki? Vaata välju.
Õpetaja: Ma korra panen selle sama sisu siia. No on täpselt sama.
Õpetaja: City Id City Id onni, aga nüüd, ma saan visuaalselt korra seda nagu näidata, kui ma teen Refresh I ära.
Õpetaja: Sest mul ei ole visuaalselt võimalik seda kuidagi muud moodi kuvada aga nüüd kohe on
Õpetaja: Noh, katki oled, vä?
Õpetaja: Ei, Ole, nii.
Õpetaja: Mis on praegult? Ee, väljude sees. Ma teen korra uuesti. Lahti. Näete, siin on kogu see Selectbox On roheline Seal Highlight I,
Õpetaja: mis on igaühe vaik ja väärtus peidetud.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt String City, Id String City, Id Strings City Id
Õpetaja: Praegult siis Võtmeks läheb ka igale asjale. Täpselt sama väärtus. String City Id. Mis probleem siin on?
Õpetaja: Ahah, Kovin.
Õpetaja: Noh, on hardcoded. Jah, ongi, et ei Tule nagu sellest objektist.
Õpetaja: Kui me soovime anda atribuudile mingit väärtust. See on tag I sees esimese tag I sees. Oleme
Õpetaja: mingisugust väärtust mis Ei ole nagu mingi veemodel ega asi.
Õpetaja: Kui me soovime Mistahes atribuut. Kla Class on atribuut.
Õpetaja: Glass, või kas anname siia Ptn?
Õpetaja: Aga kui Me sooviksime, et hoopis mingi stiil tuleb mingist programmiliselt teksti. Mingi mu mingist muutujast.
Õpetaja: Semi Kool on.
Õpetaja: Palun Vaadake need õppematerjalid. Uuesti Ära semi, Kool on on seal eraldi välja toodud. Tema praegult ei saa meelevaldselt ise otsustada,
Õpetaja: et me ei taha panna siia sellist ringi.
Õpetaja: Meil peab olema see võimalus sest kõikid Atri kõik atribuudid, Html is käivad jutumärkide sees. Ja tegelikult on tekst.
Õpetaja: Aga kui me tahame anda märku, et Kuule, ei, ei, ei, põmm.
Õpetaja: Vot nüüd midagi muutus.
Õpetaja: Kui me teeme seda väljuga ka,
Õpetaja: me saavutamegi selle, mis on nõutud.
Õpetaja: Ütleme välju sisse, läheb ka mitte. String City Id. See on see nähtamatu osa. Vaata taga, mida ei näe.
Õpetaja: Kas Nüüd on Tallinn Tartu pärnu ja siin Sees on numbrilised väärtused. Mis on need Samad City Id?
Õpetaja: Nii nagu ülesandes ongi nõutud. Ainukene asi on, et vaadake, Optionil ei ole väljut, ei ole, onju?
Õpetaja: Sellega me tegeleme ka mingi hetk.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil olemas selles mõttes. Okei, kood For Loopi jaoks. Meil on see four tsükkel ise.
Õpetaja: Mis dünaamiliselt teeb just seda elementi, mille sisse ta on defineeritud.
Õpetaja: Ta on selle elemendi. Ta on rida kaksteist. Näed, siin selle Asja tehakse nii mitu korda, kui objekti saab olema?
Õpetaja: Meil on nüüd ajutine uus muutuja nimega City.
Õpetaja: Me saame siit seest väärtusi.
Õpetaja: Me tahame panna midagi, mida inimesele kuvada.
Õpetaja: Topelt loogilised sulud. Miks sellepärast me asume tagide vahel
Õpetaja: ta. Mõtle muidu, jälle, et sa tahad kirjutada teksti, Name ei taha siin. Ma pean hoidma meeles, et ma kasutan niukest asja, et anda voele märku kui tagide vahel. See on lihtne reegel. Kuule, tagide vahel. Sa võid muutuv kasutada ainult topeltoogelised sulud.
Õpetaja: Kui oled tagide sees. Kui on veemodel, siis lihtsalt viitad objektile, kui on mingi atribuut, Näete, Ghee
Õpetaja: value, millele soovid anda objekti mingi muutuse eest väärtust, Siis see kool on. Aitab moel aru saada.
Õpetaja: Ma ei viitsiks seda üles õppida õppematerjalist ei viitsi üles otsida, Aga see on eraldi punkt. Me oleme rääkinud seda juba
Õpetaja: see on alguses raske sest et on nii Mitu varianti?
Õpetaja: Aga teil on alati väiksed vihjed.
Õpetaja: Kui te annate mingi atribuudi ja näed, te tahate teha nagu siia õiget asja. Te teate, juba, et nüüd ma pean viitama sellele City le. Kui sa kirjutad seda asja, te midagi ei paku sulle.
Õpetaja: Sa tahad viidata mingile muutmjale? Ta Ei, paku seda. Siis Ta ei saa aru, et sa mõtled muutujad. Sa näed rohelist teksti või sa näed valget teksti samamoodi
Õpetaja: ta Midagi ei taha sulle pakkuda. City.
Õpetaja: Miks ta ei paku? Mul on siin muutuja.
Õpetaja: Kas seal all või üleval? Vahet pole, sest et ta Ei saa aru,
Õpetaja: ide. Ei saa aru. Nagu. Ja tema nagu mõtleb, et sa tahadki, et kõik asjad oleks siin. Lihtsalt City,
Õpetaja: tema mõtleb, et sa tahadki teha niimoodi. Sul peab see õigus olema,
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan hardcode ida midagi sisse. Kõik linnad on hardcoditud sisse.
Õpetaja: Kõik linnad
Õpetaja: on ju? Näed, kõik linnad, Palun, väga see on minu õigus? Minu õigus on siia ka kirjutada mida iganes. Aga kui ma tahan mingid muutujad, siis ma pean talle märku andma. Oled tagide vahel
Õpetaja: topelt Loogilised sulud on veemodel või näiteks vee asjad. Ta teab, et ta räägib. Siin ei pea ütlema. Mingit siia ei pea panema. Nagu kuskile ei pea
Õpetaja: ka ei pea. Aga kui sa mistahes atribuudid näiteks value või Key.
Õpetaja: Siis kui sa tahad anda märku.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et Their roheline tekst. Valge tekst kirjutan, ei predikti Midagi Ei paku, tab Ida ei saa.
Õpetaja: See peaks olema kohe väikene. Note, et Okei, Et kui Ida praegu mõtleb seda, kui lihtsalt teksti, siis ta lihtsalt ongi tekst. Ta ei paku mulle midagi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas aitäh?
Õpetaja: See on mõeldud ka, et kui sa tahad miksida teksti ja muutujaid, ma võtan, et see on selle jaoks. Aga see on standard.
Õpetaja: Nii, Okei, saime dünaamiliselt oma selle asja siia niimoodi valmis
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis sellega niimoodi, et Ee, noh, kas Ennem kui oli see City see asi kasutatud või hiljem. Tegelikult, see on päris paras hetk, kus teha sellest selektist eraldi
Õpetaja: ei saa meetodit teha.
Õpetaja: Küll saab sellest teha komponenti.
Õpetaja: See on see koht, kus me nüüd võime teha täiesti vabalt,
Õpetaja: sest et ühtegi meetodil mingi klikkfunktsioon, selles mõttes pole et sa, et mingid meetodid käivitatakse mis Siin on all ainukene meetod, mis on siin Get Cities Ja see tõmmatakse käima, onju
Õpetaja: Nii et senikaua kuni midagi klikkida ei saa ja mingeid meetodeid ei käivita, siis mina ütlen. No nüüd, on nagu veel viimane hetk
Õpetaja: on seda ära teha, sest see tuleb varsti tegevus.
Õpetaja: Okei, kuidas?
Õpetaja: Aa, ei, muidugi. Peab olema seda ta vaikimisi niikuinii teeks nagu et vaatan ühte objekti korraga. Vaata, et Ei, see on just. See jäi puudu. Jah,
Õpetaja: see on, see, et ta annab järsku miljon rida. Ta on võimeline.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea, kas ta päriselt on võimeline, aga ütleme nii, et väga palju ridu annad. Ta on võimeline jälgima muutusi, sest et Ärge unustage ära. Vaata, et ta peab selle data. Flow järgi kuvatakse meile neid asju, mida on vaja
Õpetaja: isegi see tänane niiöelda meeldetuletus õppematerjal, mis me lugesime. Jääp is sellest ka samamoodi. Andmete pealt. Joonistame Html I.
Õpetaja: Me soovimegi niimoodi. Ja me ei taha otse asju näppida programmiliselt vaid andmete pealt. See voe ise suudab manageerida, mida on vaja näidata, kuidas ja mismoodi
Õpetaja: see süntaks on väga, väga lihtne, väga lihtne, võrreldes, Kui tahaks päriselus puhta Javascriptiga siin toimetada ja tekitada mingit tabelit või asja või mida iganes,
Õpetaja: See on ikka päris kole asi, mis seal. Taustal nagu allpool toimub.
Õpetaja: Millega me ei pea tegelema.
Õpetaja: Nii Siin kohal on mingeid küsimusi. Hetkel
Õpetaja: me teeme siis selle komponendi ära.
Õpetaja: Hästi, tähtis on, See et ei saa niimoodi võtta. Miks ei saa niimoodi võtta, selge?
Õpetaja: Jah, ma ei saa nagu mingit pooliklikku elementi jätta. Et kuule, Tee sellest eraldi krotš. Nagu, nagu Kuule, kus mu nagu pärast on.
Õpetaja: Sest te peate. Te. Kujutage ette, et see asi läheb sinna uude komponenti vahele
Õpetaja: näete. See template siin üleval. Uus komponent tekib ja tal on template.
Õpetaja: Mida iganes sina praegu siin selektid hakkab olema seal
Õpetaja: ühtlasi Ärge seda ja ma tehke. Ma kunagi ühe korra niimoodi õpetasin. Et teeme sellest asjast.
Õpetaja: Siis on see rou ka juba kohe olemas või Koll. Vaata, on Teeme. Sellest komponent. Nii mõnus, Kõik on siia, Tuleb hästi Lihtne kood. Ma ei tea, et ee, see komponent ja see komponent. Aga see on paha lugu. Sa peidad tegelikult niiöelda abstraktsioonina kuhugi madalamale. Ära
Õpetaja: Top Level top level vaatas sul ka arusaama, ära et Mi Mi, Mis see layout on? Nagu, et
Õpetaja: siin on üks, kolm. Siin on rohu kaks, kolm. Kuidas see nagu leht, nagu paigutab nagu erinevaks osadeks.
Õpetaja: Kui see oleks osa, sellest, siis Ee. Pärast on, see. Et Sul on hästi raske, nagu jälgida neid muudatusi ja taaskasutatavus muutub küsitavaks,
Õpetaja: et kui mina võtaksin praegult selle. Kui ma võtaks praegult selle täpselt siit niimoodi, koos selle kolliga ja kolm kolm
Õpetaja: ja nii edasi, Kui see oleks osa sellest komponendist. Ja nüüd me jõuame sinna kohta, kus me tahame teha. Näiteks siis seda, et Ee pangaautomaadi asukoha lisamine Seal on samamoodi
Õpetaja: vali linn, kus see uus koht hakkab olema. Kui sul on see kolumnid ja need sätted, Need stiilisätted on nagu selle sees.
Õpetaja: Kas ta sobib nüüd sinna uude kohta? Kindlasti mitte. Isegi kui ta ei sobiks, siis läheks väga abstraktseks. See mõtlemine, nagu, et Oota, mis sa leiad? Mul on, sellepärast et sul puudub ülevaade. Nii et see kokkulepe on. Ärge ärge neid rohusid ja kolla ärge. Neid kunagi komponentidesse. Toppige kaasa, kui ta on osa millestki.
Õpetaja: Sest et see ongi selle jaoks, et ma teen Row lahti ja ma vaatan, et siin on header. Teen teise kooli lahti ja ma vaatan. City Strop Town Aitäh. Rohkem, ei ole vaja tahan. Stiiliga midagi sättida
Õpetaja: sätin. Siin Neid seadistusi Nagu Css. Iga veits ja ongi korras.
Õpetaja: Nii, Control alt. Tahtsin ise Control. Altida. Parem. Klõps.
Õpetaja: Aa, komponent. Olge valmis kirjutama. Aa vaata korra. Kas see oli Cities või Citytrap Down?
Õpetaja: Ee, Peaks olema, et ta ütleb täpselt, mis siin on.
Õpetaja: City Strop on nii nii parem Klõps
Õpetaja: Refactor Extract View Component Select Selection I Cities.
Õpetaja: Ja kas see võiks olla mingi Selectbox või mis iganes up to you, kuidas kokku Lepita, et mulle tundub see kõige lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Vajutad entrit, aitad ad Ainukene asi jälle, et skript on üleval pool kattida see siit ära ja topida allapoole
Õpetaja: Võite oma projektis otsustada, et kas te tahate töötada niisuguse ee. Süsteemiga? Vaata et skript on üleval pool ja templeid allpool, te Võite seda. Teha. See on teie projekt.
Õpetaja: Üks korter kuidas? Ei, ta teeb alati selle faili juurde. Selle failiga samasse kataloogi, Kus sa selleks traktisid.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis selle tõstame. Peame siia komponentsi alla.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi Võtate kinni ja lohistate ja lasete lahti, Küsitakse üle ka refaktor ja ja kõik on? Ee, Tip Top.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, mis nüüd on. Kui ma teen lahti. Ee, siis kõik see kood, mis templetis on? Praegult seal all on on? See on mujal,
Õpetaja: mis ma säästsin Automaatselt on juba
Õpetaja: vahetust. On viis rida. Vaata, siin Line Breaks näitab alguses elektrit. Midagi. Viis rida Koodi. On juba kuskil mujal ja see on täpselt see, kuidas me soovime progeda.
Õpetaja: Me soovime, et kõik meie koodifailid oleksid selles mõttes, ee, ei oleks liiga pikad.
Õpetaja: Iga väike asi hakkab juurde ja juurde ja juurde lisama.
Õpetaja: Sa lihtsalt pildid seal peal. Siis sa näed seda originaalmas selle komponendi kasutada.
Õpetaja: Kontrollid peavad hoidma, aga siis ta läheb sinna ka nagu. No ma panen need kõik Close Other Tabs
Õpetaja: kontroll peas. Kõik Asjad muutuvad hüperrinkideks, mida saab klikkida. Kuidagi
Õpetaja: paned peal, vajutad siis Ta viib sinna
Õpetaja: ee, loomulikult controlli alt ja nool vasakule saab tagasi. Tulla edasi. Ma ei tea, kas keegi kasutab ka neid käsi püsti.
Õpetaja: Edasi liikuvad vaese mehe nupuga hiir
Õpetaja: või siis see, et sa oled võtnud selle visiooni, et. Aga ma ei kasutagi
Õpetaja: teine. Kuidas saab seda simuleerida? Kuidas seda sama kontori klik I saab simuleerida Keyboardiga. Otsi, millega otsid, Näiteks merel Uk. Nagu mingit uppujat.
Õpetaja: Keegi on merre kukkunud. Oled laeva peal?
Õpetaja: Ei, no otsid. Vaatad, et tead, et kuskil siin on keegi uppunud. Mida sa kasutad tema leidmiseks?
Õpetaja: Pinockel otsimine. Control B, palun väga.
Õpetaja: Näiteks teistpidi saab ka minna nagu ja väga ei saa. Äkki ka Lihtsalt lähete siis
Õpetaja: Leavas saab üles alla kolistada. Neid väga edukalt. Seal ei tõstagi. Seal hiirt väga ei kasutagi.
Õpetaja: Siin on veits keerulisem Nii Palju Staffi on siin, et see rullik on lihtsalt hiirel Nagu mast
Õpetaja: Kas keegi puutepadjaga ka ainult toimetab või,
Õpetaja: Ah ei ole meil masohiste Siin Ei, imesta.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame seda ka. Mis me siis kokku saime? Ee, saime siin, et. On. Ee, Vabandust, siin üleval on, kus ta tuleb, Kus ta asub?
Õpetaja: See ei muutu siis Kui me refaktoreerisime, tõstsime ümber.
Õpetaja: Öeldakse ka ära, et kasutame siin lehel komponente City Strop Down I kui seda ei ole.
Õpetaja: Asi ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Kui see komponent siin all on, on ju aga pole. Näiteks, ee. Seda importi jälle asi ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Kõik asjad peavad olemas olema. Nii
Õpetaja: väga hea.
Õpetaja: Noh, muidu võiks mõelda, et. Ee, oota, kuidas me planeerime Break I arvestades, et Ee, kuusteist. Kakskümmend viis. Ish, lasen jalga. Mulle just tundub ka, et niuke normaalne koht. Meil on nüüd järgmist sammu teha, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, jällegi Ma mõtlen, et palun, ee. Kui need asjad kõik võtavad aega, et õppida ja selgeks saada, Te peate panema kuskil selle aja sisse.
Õpetaja: Ee, Lähete koju? Vaadake, kas kui. Vaadake kõigepealt need eelmise päeva ära, et alates reedest
Õpetaja: käige need läbi. Vaadake, see kõnetab mõnus petslide Story
Õpetaja: õhtul. Ee, vaata, saate tegelikult Noh, läbi kit. I Saaksite vaadata neid ju ka täitsa vabalt Telefonist.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, usu, no palun. Väga, Teil kõigil on ligipääs sellele repositorile.
Õpetaja: Teil kõigile, kes te olete, kui te sisse loginud. Aa, ma pean vahetama.
Õpetaja: Näed, vahetan selle ära, et see saab.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei, saa enda telefonis näidata, Aga ma võin ta kompaktseks kokku tõmmata. Ja
Õpetaja: teil on ligipääs ee sellele repole.
Õpetaja: Nii ma panen bank. Nelikümmend front. Tõmbame kokku selle. Asja. Teeme siis selle asja.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei ole. Mis asja? Teeme F. Kaksteist. Mängime siis telefoni.
Õpetaja: Noh, kes on Kõige uhkema iphone kaheteist pro omanik. Vaatame, kuidas teie seda asja näete.
Õpetaja: Kas päriselt ka niimoodi? No see scroll tundub natuke kahtlane. Laius ja Pikkus võib olla. Vahet pole, Tulete telefonis siia. Klikite. Aa, toks
Õpetaja: klikid. Aa, kaustadest tuli lahti.
Õpetaja: Aa, üks asi Haru masteris. Söö me midagi. Emersi õpetaja.
Õpetaja: Kas õpetaja või õpetaja veeb? Ee üheksa Hetkel Feb üheksa. Kuna siin me toimetame.
Õpetaja: Vaatasin, et sisu nagu ei ole, nagu päris Õige, onju?
Õpetaja: Kas ta nüüd vahetas ära või mitte?
Õpetaja: Näe, on nüüd. Kaustad.
Õpetaja: Telefonist lähete? Ütlete oma kaaslane. Et Oota, ma veits näpin telefoni veel. Ma kohe jään magama. Ka Ära muretse,
Õpetaja: Ee, on eraldi. Neid võib ka vaadata materials.
Õpetaja: Noh, vaatame siis. Reede oli seitseteist
Õpetaja: teed lahti, Browser suudab Md Faili Preview Ga näidata. Vaatate, link on üleval videole. Vaata videot. Parool on olemas.
Õpetaja: On Ju Telefonis on raske otsida teemasid, Võibolla mingeid asju olete juba vaadanud.
Õpetaja: Vajutate lingile kukute alla Loete. Vaatate,
Õpetaja: Saate telefonis seda ka teha. Noh, kes ei viitsi? No minu mul on ka raskusi arvutada. Lahti teha. Äkki telefoni suudate? Saatke endale lihtsalt see õige linki juba Vaata, näete. Tulete siia kausta Ära
Õpetaja: transcript materials. Pange see link endale kuhugi Facebooki ja.
Õpetaja: Ja avata. No mis Slack on Telefonis teil kellelgi ei ole on vä. No väga hea,
Õpetaja: nüüd Tasub ära. Vaata, minul on ka sla. Üks asi, mis mulle meeldib ja mis mul telefonis on?
Õpetaja: Noh, saadame kõigile. Jah, väga noise üksteist Inimest. Üheksateist inimest saab teada. Palun. Väga viimane link.
Õpetaja: Õige kaust lugemismaterjal õhtuks.
Õpetaja: Võtate õige kuupäeva ja hakkate vaatama, mis teil räägib ja no Ma Ei, tea, kuidas ta päriselt telefonist loetav on, aga. Noh, ma arvan, mingil kujul. On.
Õpetaja: No teeme Jah, Siis lähme. Lähme. Te võite juba minna juba baasile. Ma panen selle.
Õpetaja: Te ei pea kohe pullima. Praegult, onju? Te saate pärast seda
Õpetaja: ka, teha, et kui mitu on siin iga kord nagu mingi miljon aastat aega võtnud. Push Õigemini
Õpetaja: Tuled, tagasi või me ei lähe ennem ära koju, kui sa tagasi tuled, Korraks Homme hommikul lähme ära.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei,
Õpetaja: Aa, seal Spreadsheet Il on juba see videolink. Tänane on olemas. Lihtsalt siit saad mõlemad videod korraga. Seal on see Play nupu kõrval. Ee, tekst. Sest isu veel ei ole. Mõlemad video Next nupuga vaadata. Video number kaks, Palun Väga
Õpetaja: spons ja valge. Ainult siis, kui me kasutame
Õpetaja: me seda kuskilt endist. Tahame infot saada. See on. See on see, mis see tähendab vä,
Õpetaja: ma ei tahtnud midagi aru saama.
Õpetaja: Sa pead aru saama, et vaata. Näiteks väger näitab visuaalselt. Vaata, mida see teenus nagu tagastab, on ju Vaata, See respons on kogu see punane kast, kogu kõik kast, Aga aga
Õpetaja: seitse seotud. Kellegagi ei ole. See See on sildikene.
Õpetaja: See esimene kord Kui sa sulgudes kirjutades tuleb see noor. See on sildikene. Sinna tehnoloogia ise paneb selle kogu respons. Objekti panebki. Sa võid sinna kirjutada Nipitiri Ka selle responsi asemel. Siis nipitirju sees.
Õpetaja: No siit vähe.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mida see viies koud teeb. Palju tahaprogramm on sellise.
Õpetaja: See teeb nii palju asju sinu eest ära. Ei, noh, oskama peab. Ta on ikkagi nagu koodi Ahvid praegult kirjutama, nagu päriselt, aga jah, ta väga palju teeb, ära onju?
Õpetaja: See on, see on väga hea. Ma ütlen, et isegi enne seda Aid juba oli kogeda
Õpetaja: Jah, korraks siis. Jah. Davai. Aa, nii sobib nii ka
Õpetaja: kolm korda.
Õpetaja: Mhm aa.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt on väike
Õpetaja: korteri vähe.
Õpetaja: See ei ole minu jaoks nii.
Õpetaja: Mhmh Ma ei ole sellist kultuur.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Ee, ee.
Õpetaja: Pildid tulevad.
Õpetaja: Jah, kes küsimus
Õpetaja: Lasteaias
Õpetaja: kaks või viissada päeva omavahel.
Õpetaja: Jah, kuidas kasutada.
Õpetaja: Jälgida.
Õpetaja: Palun Sul on ka. Mis te tahate? Ülesse pilt kabi juurde
Õpetaja: Ja sinna tuleb info. Kui sul on mingi.
Õpetaja: Jah, see on see see üks kord,
Õpetaja: Aitäh,
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: ainult. Ee, Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Toetust
Õpetaja: või kaks minutit välja.
Õpetaja: Kuidas siis piitsa oli? Hendrik, soovitad.
Õpetaja: Aa kaks. Viiekümne Vist Täiesti Viimata ei saa, onju Nagu
Õpetaja: Uksepõhjaline seega. Selline väga tugevalt pepperooni maitsmine et, ee nõud istume pitsa
Õpetaja: mulle. Sobib ma. Eelistangi jõukese põhjal veel
Õpetaja: kui, ma ei ole Ei ole tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ee, teksti too.
Õpetaja: Tere.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: ei või.
Õpetaja: Aitäh, Väiksed vabadus.
Õpetaja: See on,
Õpetaja: eks?
Õpetaja: Kuuled?
Õpetaja: Päris,
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: Mhmh
Õpetaja: okei, Absoluutselt Jah, Ee,
Õpetaja: õhtul.
Õpetaja: No see läks hästi.
Õpetaja: Kindlasti ei ole. Vabanda, ei, saa,
Õpetaja: professor.
Õpetaja: Ma ei ole nelikümmend.
Õpetaja: Tahad,
Õpetaja: See jääb nagu
Õpetaja: Tere, ei ole kohe nagu on. Täpselt.
Õpetaja: Muidugi
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: ma arvan.
Õpetaja: Jah, ja jah, täpselt pole.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt tõuse püsti. Jah, jah, ma hakkan minema.
Õpetaja: Kohe
Õpetaja: tuleb.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: Kiusa lehti kell me pausile läksime. Ma ei pannud ise tähele.
Õpetaja: Okei üldiselt.
Õpetaja: Kas sa ütleks neile?
Õpetaja: Hakkame tulema? Mis asja arvad, minna nagu Tsau minema.
Õpetaja: Viimase lehe ka.
Õpetaja: No seda ma julgeks küsida. Ma olen kuulnud, et seal on siukest asja, nagu ütles.
Õpetaja: No ja ma ei oska midagi sealt.
Õpetaja: Kuulge, aga anname siis. Ee, kuuma.
Õpetaja: Ma tegelt ühe küsimuse. Küsin Chat I käest. Ma küsin kogu aeg Ee Css iga Tuleb
Õpetaja: näidetel Mingid erinevad mingid Aria label ja mis iganes see tekst tundub nagu mingi
Õpetaja: ee, kus kus see kasutuses on, Nagu, et ta ei kuva nagu funktsionaalsust. Ta ei mõjuta, et ma küsiks hea meelega Cloudi käest, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: me anname selle rea talle kõigepealt. Control K On ju, K? Anname selle rea. Aga täpsemalt selle osa
Õpetaja: ma küsin. Ee, mida see teeb või mida see üldse mõjutab, kui mõjutab
Õpetaja: natuke suuremaks. Ma panen siia, siis ma panen lihtsalt selle teksti ka. Nagu see osa mind huvitab.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma olen nüüd aastaid alati maa krattinud, Aga ma pole kunagi mõelnud, nagu. Et.
Õpetaja: Et nagu What stabil Big Beal, nagu et.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ta ütleb mulle meile nagu mitte midagi, Siis on, nagu pole vaja
Õpetaja: visuaalselt mitte midagi. Browser Is ei kuvatud seda. Kasutajal funktsionaalselt Ainult abitehnoloogiat. Kasutavatel Inimestel on halvem kogu kogemus, sest Nad kuulevad mõttetut teksti
Õpetaja: Default Select Example. Selle asemel, et kuulda midagi asjaliku nagu
Õpetaja: soovitus, muuda see mõistlikuks ahah. Ehk, Siis, ühesõnaga on ikkagi Jälle need kõnesüntesaatorid Ja asjad Täita mõttes ta ära,
Õpetaja: et see label on siis nagu kui inimene läheb selle Selecti peale, näiteks mingi tabiga, Või mis iganes abivahend neil on, Kuidas nad Browserist navigeerivad? Siis ta ütleb arvatavasti selle teksti. Lihtsalt välja
Õpetaja: vali linn vastast niiöelda, kas meil Keegi veel puudu kes müüdu klassis oli?
Õpetaja: Me Lähme igal juhul oma õppetunniga edasi. Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis ma järgmiseks tahan, et me teeme on niimoodi Step by step.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks luua niukse võimekuse, et juhul kui mina. Aa, kui me võtame selle veebilehe niiöelda lahti, kas
Õpetaja: paus vist läks ka peale. Aga Okei, las ta läks. Onju, et minu mõte on see, et mina tahaks niimoodi kustutada lehte laev,
Õpetaja: siis ta Vaikimisi valiks selle kõik linnad. Aga esialgu ma tahan teha niimoodi et hoopis vaikimisi valiks midagi. Muud.
Õpetaja: No näiteks Tartu
Õpetaja: Nüüd me peame aru saama, et iga selle option I taga Tegelikult, Aa, konkreetselt, on meil väljuväärtus,
Õpetaja: et kui ma võtan selle selekti lahti, võtan näiteks Ee Tartu, Siis tema välju on hetkel kolm, mis on ühtegi tema City, On see arusaadav?
Õpetaja: Ee, et saavutame kõigepealt seda, et meie oleme siin.
Õpetaja: Me Suudame manipuleerida seda, et ee, mis väärtus sealt all valitakse.
Õpetaja: Mm, võibolla ühe asja Ma näitan ka veel Isegi teeme teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: See on kaastegemise koht.
Õpetaja: Hetkel on siin Props Cities ja siis viitaks tüübina. Öeldakse, et on mingi objekt, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui me teame tublikaadi, siis ja mõtleme ühe niukse uue Propsi välja Nagu Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina saan tegelikult siin tüübina samamoodi, nagu saaks siin tegelikult öelda Object,
Õpetaja: et mis tüüpi see asi on?
Õpetaja: Saan ma siin öelda, et Selected City It? Mis tüüpi tema on?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui te mõtlete, nagu mis tüüpi saaks olla
Õpetaja: integraal, aga on üleüldiselt kõik number.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd hetke seisuga on need mõlemad niiöelda kohustuslikud Props väljend
Õpetaja: ja kui ma seda kuskil kasutan, Siis, ee, justkui. Ee, see nii on.
Õpetaja: Ma saan, teha, Aga ütleme. See on nagu näitamise heaks, et, ee, Ma annan sellele väike väärtuse, Aga Siis on see, et mul on tüüpi ikka vaja. Nagu. Mis tüüpi sa oled?
Õpetaja: Siis On meil selline võimalus et me kasutame ee, loogilisi sulgusi. Ja meil on laiendatud võimalused
Õpetaja: igast erinevad. Ma ei tea, kas ta pakub ka või mitte, igasugused atribuudid ja asjad nagu mida On võimalik siis nagu ära defineerida. Üks Nendeks on näiteks Taipe
Õpetaja: Taipe peale Taipei koolonid. Ma saan öelda endiselt, et tegemist on numbriga.
Õpetaja: Nii Noh, kui sa praegu mõelda, et nagu mis on nagu selle erinevus ja selle erinevus, polegi midagi.
Õpetaja: Kui sa paned kohe Taipei, siis ta on. Nagu Kui sa soovid natukene rohkem asju panna, siis ma endiselt tahan Taipei panna. Aga ma tahan võibolla midagi muud ka panna
Õpetaja: ee Näiteks vaikimisi väärtus.
Õpetaja: Default,
Õpetaja: et lihtsalt midagi proovida ja näha, et see tõesti töötab, siis ma panen siia selle sama kolm, niiöelda default value,
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd, kui, ee, vaadata meie seda Tegelikult, Vaata, Siin võtab kaasa kaks Props i Cities ja Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Täpselt nii nagu siin Kirjas on üks ja kaks Selle tasub kokku tõmmata, on ju? Noh, on nii,
Õpetaja: kaks on neid, aga see nüüd on tehtud niimoodi, et Juhul kui mingit väärtust ei tule siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Me ju näeme ju City S. Anname kaasa. Aga mina ei näe kuskil Siin nagu kool On ju Selected City Id? Üks näiteks, onju? Ei ole, onju?
Õpetaja: Võtan selle tagasi, et seda ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd teen, lahti, Ee, Voe niiöelda tööriista selle. Võtan selle lahti ja vaatan tema Child Elementi. Näete, nüüd hakkab tulema, onju? Child Element
Õpetaja: siis, mis on hetkel see Electricity Id. Väärtus
Õpetaja: kolm. Aga kui ma teen niimoodi, et ma lähen? Siia
Õpetaja: Vabandust, kus kutsutakse välja seda komponenti, ütlen Selected City Id panen võrdub ja panen siia hoopis kaks.
Õpetaja: Siis lähme vaatame, mis on nüüd tema väärtus seal
Õpetaja: lahti. Atm Cities on. Kaks Kas te saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Meil on võimalik
Õpetaja: kaasa anda mingi väärtus. Aga me saame ära ka defineerida selle asja, et juhul kui mitte ööd ega mütsi ei Tule siis. Mis väärtus siiski on? Selleks, et kood üleval töötab
Õpetaja: Küsimusi.
Õpetaja: Mis See, mugavus on See, et võibolla seda sama elementi ma tahan niimoodi kasutada, et talle läheb mingi väärtus kaasa.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla ma ei soovigi, et tal läheb mingisugune väärtus kaasa. Näiteks
Õpetaja: ma tegelikult ikkagi nüüd Lõppkokkuvõttes ütlen, et läheb
Õpetaja: See, mis kaasa antakse. Plaan on seda manageerida.
Õpetaja: Ja miks selgub? Ee, veits. Aja pärast, nagu et miks on ikkagi vaja Miks on vaja siia niukest Selected City, Id D.
Õpetaja: No, praegult on niimoodi, et see number tõesti on seal, annan kaasa läheb praegu Kaks
Õpetaja: idee järgi. Kui ma valiks siit selle, siis see kaks rehkenduks. Ee, vaatame, millest rehkenduks Kaks, kus meil on kaks tallinn peaks olema,
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida meie tahame teha, on see, et meie oma hetkel on see kaks sisse kirjutatud. Aga me tahame niimoodi, et see läheb muutuja Seest,
Õpetaja: mis me peame tegema siis, kui see, et me ei taha lihtsalt kirjutada, et
Õpetaja: koodi sisse seda kahtlevad, et ta läheksid muutuja seest, Siis peame tegema.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on ka ju. Muutuja on, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja Ja
Õpetaja: Lovelyiseb.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, me jõuame pika ringiga sinna, siis Topelt loogilised sulud. Aga miks topelt Loogilised sulud? Kas ma olen tagide vahel?
Õpetaja: Kui sa oled kohe tähe, vahel näiteks vaata, ja kirjutad tekste Näiteks H. Üks kiskas
Õpetaja: siis. On? Kool on juba siin.
Õpetaja: Point on see, et meil. Ma ütlengi, et meil ongi muutujat vaja, et meil ei ole ühtegi sobivat muutujat siin praegu. Siin on.
Õpetaja: Siin on Role Name. Siin on Citys on
Õpetaja: meil. Kui Me soovime, et siia ei Läheks lihtsalt väärtus Kaks alla, vaid läheb mingist muutujast. Ma ütlesin, et meil on vaja mingit muutujat, et meil olekski siin vaja
Õpetaja: mingid muutused siin all, aga ma ei taha. Ma tahan siin samamoodi Selected City Id
Õpetaja: ja paneme siia. Näiteks praegult väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Kaks.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siin, ei peaks kasutama enam seda väärtust. Kaks vaid siin.
Õpetaja: Jah, minul läks. Jooksis kooma siin. Ee, Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Me saame endiselt nüüd veenduda, et Noh, ma panen mingi muu numbri Ma panen siis praegu mingi neli. Vaata, ma pole kordasid kasutanud. Me saame endiselt niiöelda veenduda, et kas ta tegelikult sinna alla jõuab või mitte? Noh, Props on seal all komponendis.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma teen selle siit lahti ja panen, siis tundub, et see voolab sinna Propsiga alla. On on see arusaadav? Näed,
Õpetaja: meil on Atms just datablokis muutuja Selected City Id. Seda väärtust saame meie Siin meie saame muuta programmiliselt või kuidas iganes me saame seda muuta,
Õpetaja: seda me ei saa vähemalt selles City Strop Town Is Endas kunagi muuta.
Õpetaja: Mitte kunagi, ainult.
Õpetaja: Ee, saame.
Õpetaja: Ee, se. See tuleb siia sisse samamoodi. Need asjad peavad voolama sisse. Propsi voolavad asjad sisse.
Õpetaja: Propsi muutmine Childis on keelatud.
Õpetaja: Props ei tohi olla seotud interaktiivselt ühegi elemendiga, mis muudaks tema väärtust veemudelit. Me ei taha Propsiga osta, ei tohi,
Õpetaja: tema Väärtus tuleb alati ülevalt.
Õpetaja: Samamoodi nagu siin. Siin ei ole ju kirjas. Vaata, kui datablokis on see, kus me saame, panen selle siia vasakule, Paneme üles siia alla, nagu
Õpetaja: on meil muutujad, mille sisu me saame defineerida ja muuta.
Õpetaja: Propsis ei ole. Siin.
Õpetaja: Ei ole nagu mudelit ei Ole mitte midagi. Siin on see tüüp, mis seal sisse käib?
Õpetaja: Kõik, nii okei,
Õpetaja: jõuame pika ringi ka, sinna Aga okei, ee, Nüüd, mis me tahame teha, on see. No ma panen siis kolm või midagi, mis oli Tartu vist oli Või Mis iganes
Õpetaja: nüüd meie mõte on See, et siin selles City Strop Town Is me. Tahame teha niimoodi et, see
Õpetaja: sellel selektil on alamelemendid optionid Optionite Sees on välju igaühe Sees on välju, välja arvatud ühe sees ei ole väljut. No, siin on ju välju. Vaata vastavalt City Id Le tuleb välju, millest ma Jäpin sellest.
Õpetaja: Ma nende numbri nende valikute taga.
Õpetaja: Nende valikute taga. On Tegelikult numbrid.
Õpetaja: Kus ta on siin?
Õpetaja: Ei, no tõenäoliselt siit. Inspekt kas on iga valiku taga. Number Value.
Õpetaja: See on Attribuut Value Ainukene, millel hetkel ei ole, on kõik linad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina teen ettepaneku, et me Teeme niimoodi, et kõik linnal on ka välju.
Õpetaja: No siis me ütlemegi atribuut value selle Optionil
Õpetaja: ja mina pakun, et paneme selle väärtuseks null,
Õpetaja: Aga ta väikene fookus pookus, Et ta mõtleb seda kui numbrit. Ma ütlen, et ma tahan siia mingit muutujat, aga annan otseväärtusel Nüüd ta on nagu päriselt null. Nüüd ta on nagu null. String
Õpetaja: seal on. Seal on erinevus.
Õpetaja: Pärast räägime. Miks? Kuidas näitan? Hiljem
Õpetaja: Ee, me tahame seda kõik linna ja teha selliselt, et me saame seda hiljem kasutada ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellel hetkel, kui, ee. Me kasutame seda sama
Õpetaja: või me Tahame muuta olemasoleva pangaautomaadi andmeid.
Õpetaja: Siis mis me tahame teha, on see, et kasutajale tuleb anda võimalus.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, kui ta saabub kuhugi lehele ja ta soovib midagi muuta. Valib mustamäe prisma ja vajutab mingi Teddid nuppu. Mäletad? Mängisime seal seda Flow D läbi. Ta satub kuhugi Vormilehele, kus on eeltäidetud väljad?
Õpetaja: Noh, juba ongi ees. Mustamäe prisma ja kolm pangaautomaati Sularaha sisse välja. Kõik on täidetud.
Õpetaja: No seal on ka ju dropdown. Ja seal on linnadega, on ju.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et meil peab olema võimekus, et me saame teha niimoodi, et kui see laetakse,
Õpetaja: siis seal on juba valitud. Õige pin
Õpetaja: praegult. Meil ei ole seda selles mõttes vaja. Praegu me soovime, et kui me tuleme, siis Nendest kõikidest valikutest on see option, mille välju on
Õpetaja: null, on valitud.
Õpetaja: Nii Okei, Davai.
Õpetaja: Aa siis. Kuidas seda teha on see, et sellel Selectboxil. Endal on atribuut value.
Õpetaja: Palju võrdub enam. Kindel kes see ikkagi oli,
Õpetaja: Kui paneme mingi väetise Ja nüüd, kus me tahame saada, me ei taha jälle. Vaata, ma ütlen, kui ma praegu siia paneks Selle sisse. Vaata, paneks kaks
Õpetaja: näiteks. Ta töötab või mitte. Mis on, mis on vaikimise valitud. Kui ma tulen siia, töötab, onju? Ja Refresh
Õpetaja: Puita Loodan ühe korra veel.
Õpetaja: Nojah, ta on nagu, ee, string kaks,
Õpetaja: nüüd On ta nagu number kaks korraks. Ta nagu näitab.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei soovigi, et see välju. Tuleb mingi sissekirjutatud väärtusega, vaid ta tuleb hoopis sellest. Props Ist Selected City Id
Õpetaja: ehk siia. Me kirjutame Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: No nüüd töötab korrektselt.
Õpetaja: Meie pärend
Õpetaja: annab kaasa Selected City Id väärtuse. No, näeme antakse kaasa Citys ja Selected City Id. Võibolla see järjestus võiks ka olla korrektne. City City Id. No, kellest seal niipidi Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: et, ee. Me näeme, et meil tõesti.
Õpetaja: Meie Atms Views on Selected City Id väärtus kolm.
Õpetaja: See Flow alla Child I.
Õpetaja: Ma Pean ütlema ka, et kui midagi ei ole, vaata siis. Aa, ma kaotasin sealt default väärtuse ära. Vaata on ju, Aga okei, las ta olla
Õpetaja: nii selline asi. See lehte juures survestab teda midagi valima.
Õpetaja: Praegult. See väärtus on kolm ja tänu sellele valitakse
Õpetaja: nende auto nende vabandust, Nende asukohtade seast. Just see välju. Teeme lahti, aga ma teen selle kliki all. Inspekt.
Õpetaja: Miks on vaikimisi tartu? Sest et Tartu välju on Kolm
Õpetaja: ja see, mis sinna sisse niiöelda ujub City Strop Town I On kolm nagu, ma muudan selle siit ära näiteks. On hea näidata Ma panen hoopis kaks
Õpetaja: on tallinn. Nüüd vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Ta on natuke laiemaks. Seda
Õpetaja: on tallinn.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen siit, muudan selle väärtuse üheks on pärnu.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen, muudan selle nulliks on kõik linnad,
Õpetaja: Sest et iga Option I juures on oma välju.
Õpetaja: Teda just nägime Iga Option I juures on oma value ja see atribuut at value mis sinna, sisse läheb Praegu selekteerib just selle asja,
Õpetaja: mis on nii nüüd Meie ülesanne nõuab seda, et
Õpetaja: kui meie nüüd valime midagi Siit
Õpetaja: ma korra toon need suhted siia. Kui Meie, siit City Strop Down ist, Valime mingisuguse valiku. Siis selle Selected City Id, mis on? Me nagu valime. See info peab minema teatena ülesse meie
Õpetaja: eesmärk, et hiljem vastavalt Sellele valikule kuvatakse tabelites just selle linna asukohti, mille Id on valitud
Õpetaja: Ee andmebaasi värk jälle korra ette panna.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil on asukohad Locations Tsikupilli prisma tondiselver võiks asukohti juurde tekitada. Mis ta City Id on?
Õpetaja: Kaks nii vähe asju ma pärast panen Scripti ka juurde praegu. Noh, Okei,
Õpetaja: pärast praegu. Vahet pole, me veel Ei, ei küsi niikuinii siit andmeid. Niikuinii tuleb stoplight ist.
Õpetaja: Kõik meie andmed, kas Te saate mõttest, aru,
Õpetaja: et meil on vaja sellest. Näed, parent on kogu see roheline osa Atms View.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja teada, mida Childis valitakse.
Õpetaja: Noh, Child vajab andme. Meil on see Child Child I sees on andmed.
Õpetaja: Child peab teavitama pärendud sündmusest või muutustest.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on esimest korda hoopis sündmus Või muutus
Õpetaja: saab kaasa anda ka mingi paki objekti andmetega, mida peab. Mis See pakk meile on?
Õpetaja: Selected City Id, on, mis meid huvitab,
Õpetaja: Sest et see toimub alamkomponent. Ja siis meil on Forever and Ever Niukene City, Strop Town Mis, ei ole tegelikult seotud ühegi teise komponendiga
Õpetaja: Jah, tal on tarbijad, kes seda kasutavad,
Õpetaja: aga tema ise ei ole seotud. Mitte kellegagi
Õpetaja: Kui ta ainuke asi, mis ma selle ära saan, Peame programmeerima. On see, et teatud õigel ajal hetkel. Tema annab ülespoole. Teate, toimus sündmus. Uus linn valiti ja annab Pakikese kaasa, et näed City Id kaks on, mis valiti?
Õpetaja: See on kõik, kes tema pärend on. Ei ole ühteainsat koodirida, nagu vähemalt selles lapses endas, kui me Vaatame City Strop Town I. Siin. Ei saa olema mitte ühtegi viidet
Õpetaja: see. Pole Nagu mitte kuidagi öeldud kuidagi atms Viu Või mida iganes
Õpetaja: siin ei ole siin on template Siin on Selectbox.
Õpetaja: Siin on name. Siin on Props ja siin on kõik.
Õpetaja: Ta on eraldi seisev klots Ja Just sellisena me tahamegi oma elemente ehitada.
Õpetaja: Ma saan seda veel kasutada.
Õpetaja: Anna mulle siia mingi sisu ja tema muudkui Annab Id vastu, Nagu mida valiti. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: see ei peaks isegi olema tingimata City Strop Down
Õpetaja: Siin saaks teha ka üleüldiselt niukse. Väga üleüldise.
Õpetaja: Anna mulle. Mingi Massiiv label, name
Õpetaja: ja label Id. Näiteks. Anna mulle mingid sellised andmed.
Õpetaja: Noh, muidugi, siis oleks väga paha lugu, et peaksid tulema niuksed, objektid, Kus on ka
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt samad väljad. Mingi label name ja label Id.
Õpetaja: Aga siis see, nagu ei ole, Annan mulle linnaandmed ja siis ta annab mingi label name label Id. Näiteks. Need andmed peavad ju kattuma välja nimed ja asjad,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes ta on ikkagi seotud konkreetse Aga vähemalt kus iganes. Kujutage ette suuremat mõõtu. Mingisugune Aa suuremat mõõtu Ee, rakendus.
Õpetaja: Seal saab olema päris palju mingisuguseid erinevaid rokone, mis tegelikult Ühel või teisel viisil kuskil korduvad jälle,
Õpetaja: et saab vali midagi. Noh, noh, mingid tüübid või mingid asjad. Noh, toome näiteid. Näiteks ka epoes
Õpetaja: Mingid tüübid on mingid kodutarbed, aiatooted, kategooriad, elektroonika, kodumasinad. Need on ju andmed ju?
Õpetaja: Need Võibolla ei ole tingimata tegelikult isegi niiöelda esitletud nad Peavad ka nupud alla ja või lingi.
Õpetaja: Aga nad tegelikult on ikkagi tüübid ja andmed ja võib ka tullaina ja kujutame ette, et kui teekski midagi, siis tõesti. See seal on. See konks on see, et Noh, seal, on ruumi taaskasutuseks või isegi kui ei ole, siis ta on vähemalt eraldi file, et, ee, mis? Ütleme ka need read, mis kõik on, siin Ei, ole kuskil mujal,
Õpetaja: kui juba ühes kohas on Vähemalt topelt kordus Vaatad. Kahes kohas kasutad, Siis ei ole enam ühtegi Excuse. Miks peaks see koodirida olema? Kuskil mingisuguse vaate Sees näiteks
Õpetaja: Kui Teda on kahes kohas täpselt samamoodi. Põhimõtteliselt üks komponent taaskasutaja.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me peame siis tegema teda natukene ümber Vaata et teda on võimalik selliselt kasutada, et me saame temalt informatsiooni ka kätte.
Õpetaja: Ja siin tuleb siis ee, niiöelda kasutusele kaks asja.
Õpetaja: Üks asi on see, et meil On vaja Event selle interaktiivse elemendiga tekitada. Mingi sündmus.
Õpetaja: Teiseks siis, kui see sündmus käivitab, siis ta peab Aa teavitama pärandit koos andmetega. Meil on Siin erinevad võimalused. Erinevad võimalused Selles mõttes, et me saame natukene progeda Kui see asi ei lähe väga metsikuks
Õpetaja: kohe siinsamas kohas, kus Me nagu, Aa sätestame ära, et teatud sündmuse puhul niiöelda hakka. Midagi tegema. Teine variant on see, et me teeme eraldi meetodi. Nime Teeme eraldi meetodi
Õpetaja: mingi nimelise meetodi. Ja me siis kutsume seda välja. Ma näitan teile mõlemat varianti ja me enamvähem lepime kokku. Kuidas me toimetame.
Õpetaja: See võib olla ka miks. See on. Ee. Miks see on match?
Õpetaja: Miks see match tähendab seda, et me ei pea tingimata valima ühte mustrit ja sada protsenti sellest kinni hoidma vaid vastavalt oma oma mingisugustele otsustuskohale, Nagu, kus me kasutame. Nagu niukest, otse
Õpetaja: otse kirjutamist ja kus Me loome juurde ühe meetodi. Ja mõned kohad on hästi kohad, kus tuleb meetod teha. Mõned kohad on nagu sellised, kus nagu mõlemad lähenemised saavad olema toetatud, Ja siis. On lihtsalt valikute küsimus.
Õpetaja: Valik üks,
Õpetaja: mis igal juhul peab juhtuma on see, et selle interaktiivsel elemendil on erinevad Aa, mehhanismid Mis temaga saab üldse juhtuda?
Õpetaja: Ma panen teeme alustuseks. Hästi, Lihtsalt ät click.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ääd, click.
Õpetaja: Ee. Võrdub nii
Õpetaja: aa. Et, seda Natuke demoda oleks vaja alert meetodid käivitada, aga ta ei oska seda siit teha Demo,
Õpetaja: meetod, bloki. Ja ma teen siia lihtsalt meetodi, hello
Õpetaja: Ja kõik, mis ta hello teeb, on lihtsalt aler. See võib ka praegu tegelikult vaatamise kohta olla, sest see on kustutamise kaup.
Õpetaja: Ee, teen seal. Hei, hei, nüüd selle ät Click i peale. Ma saan panna, et käivita see. Hello,
Õpetaja: See oli niimoodi. Step by step minnes nagu,
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kuidas see asi nüüd käivitu käitub. Kui ma vajutan siia peale tuli. Hei, Hei, oletan, nõus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me mõtleme seda, et meil on vaja saada kätte seda Id D.
Õpetaja: Mida me valisime, siis? Kas ma olen midagi veel üldse valinud
Õpetaja: Ei ole, see oli klikk, onju?
Õpetaja: See Click on üks võimalustest, mida saab teha siia selle interaktiivse elemendiga.
Õpetaja: Aga siin on veel teisi variante ka.
Õpetaja: Kas siit jääb midagi silma, Mis võiks võibolla tunduda loogilisem Change
Õpetaja: siin juba on nüüd Siis selline asi. Et Ee, see Change on tegelikult defineeritud selle selektiga ära Vaatad, Kuidas ta nagu siin kontekstis on?
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis on siin Change. Millal tuleb Refresh?
Õpetaja: Kui ma klikin peale. Kas see, on Change?
Õpetaja: Kas tuli Hello ei tulnud sisu.
Õpetaja: Jah, kui ma klikin tagasi kinni tulen. Klikin tartu peale. Kas midagi on muutunud? Klikin, Ära ka su mingi fookuse Välja Minemine ja nii edasi ei ole.
Õpetaja: James on ainult siis kui ma vali midagi uut.
Õpetaja: Vot nii et te hakkaksite saama aru, et Meil on erinevad Evend Id, mis võivad juhtuda Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd. Aa, see Hello.
Õpetaja: Kohe teeme seda Võibolla pikalt ka. Korra Kustutame ära.
Õpetaja: Mida me Tahame teha, mis ma ennem rääkisin. Vanem
Õpetaja: peab saama teadma, et toimus mingi sündmus ja andma meile
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt siis Selected City Id väärtuse,
Õpetaja: ta Peab andma nagu väärtuse, mida? Mis on selle taga õigemini väärtuse? Ta peab andma selle välju, mis meil on selle option I taga, mida Me valime, see on missioon.
Õpetaja: Siis me saame tegelikult siin kohe käivitada Niukse asja nagu.
Õpetaja: No see on. Ta vist tahab dollari märki, aga natuke kirjutad, siis Ta tuleb Tabiga ka limit,
Õpetaja: mida ootab ja mitte enda sisse. Oleme varem rääkinud. Ta ootab kahte asja esimesel Kohal. On Mingisugune identifikaator. Vaata, et me ütleme mingi sündmuse nimel, mis siin toimub
Õpetaja: ja teine asi peale koma saame saata mingisuguse paki, kui tahame saata Nii okei, väga hea sinule peamegi saada.
Õpetaja: Siis me peamegi paki saatma. Jah, sul on õigus.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: proovime. See tuleb Niukene Step by Step kahjuks. Nüüd hakkab natukene virrvarriks ära minema. Aga thats how it is
Õpetaja: nii on.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, mis siis saama hakkab. Kui mina küll Kirjutan siia emit I.
Õpetaja: Praegult oli mõte. Ma Oleks pidanud tegema eraldi haru. Päev Kaks Edaspidi teen ma endale. Vähemalt haru Ee, hommik ja õhtu arake ära. Miks
Õpetaja: koodi näited? Videos, kui ma teen ühe?
Õpetaja: Jah, ma pean mõtlema natukene seda asja veel. Jah, ilmselt küll. Ma tahan edaspidi teha. Natuke paremini veel. Ma mõtlesin praegu need materjalid ja asjad, mis ta kõik toodab.
Õpetaja: Nüüd selle miti juures on vaja mingisugust sündmuse nime. Ma Olen varasemalt öelnud, et mulle meeldib üks Prefix.
Õpetaja: Ee, kasutada sõnumis
Õpetaja: See defineerib. Ee, kus me oleme mitte varem kasutanud, kes mäletab,
Õpetaja: Mida üheksakümmend kuus login rida. Vot väga hea tubli. Like. Rida Üheksakümmend kuus.
Õpetaja: Siim Mis Siin see teade oli?
Õpetaja: Event user, Loged in kes Kinnipüüdja oli ja keegi mäletab, kes pärand on. Login Viole.
Õpetaja: No mis? Mis pidi juhtuma sellise sündmusega või kasutaja logist sisse?
Õpetaja: Keegi pärend pidi natuke ennast siis visuaalselt muutma. Millest räägime?
Õpetaja: Logi? Sisse Logi välja. No menüü.
Õpetaja: Kui läheme Up ueesse, siis näeme, et siin on Niukene rida Nagu Routerview.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb Event user Loged in, siis käivita mingi meetod.
Õpetaja: Nii, see on samamoodi, et keegi, viskas selle sündmuse,
Õpetaja: mis meil siin See muster on, mis see on
Õpetaja: ja teeme niimoodi, et meil on alati Event nüüd siin. Me tahame samamoodi teha, et me ütleme, et Ee, on üks sündmus selle. See on nüüd kiri, mis läheb tuvile jala külge. Event.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mõtleme seda sellises vaatepilgus et ee, et seda näeb seda seda kirja. Tegelikult see. See tekst on meie jaoks. See sündmuse tekst on oluliselt ee rohkem tähtis seal kohas,
Õpetaja: kus me seda Komponenti niiöelda kasutame ja välja kutsume. Ehk siis siia. Tuleb see kinnipüüdja kuskile.
Õpetaja: Siin vaadates City Strop Town I Peaks see event Nagu see Sõnum peaks meid kõnetama, et mis toimus? Mis toimus City Strop Town Is Mis. See vend sealt tuleb
Õpetaja: sest? Et siin me näeme koodi kõike ja siin. Me ei taha kirjutada, et mida ta teeb, vaid me tahame kirjutada, mis juhtus,
Õpetaja: Sest et me, loeme seda siin.
Õpetaja: Mis Võiks olla kliendi nimi.
Õpetaja: Kujutage ette, et siia tullakse samamoodi. Ma korra mõtlen nüüd natukene. Ee, siin. Ee, Te võite juba kirjutada ka Me Teeme nüüd niukest asja, et see üksik tag läheb liiga pikaks, Muidu.
Õpetaja: Aa, et me kirjutame natukene üksteise alla
Õpetaja: kui ma kirjutaksin siia vend I nime siis öelge, mida teie sooviksite siin näha.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan City Strop Town Ja nüüd näen et, mingi event
Õpetaja: Mis. Juhtus seal city. Strop down is. See See peaks olema nüüd kuidagi kirjaviisis.
Õpetaja: Noh, valiti linn. Vaata, on ju midagi taolist väljuma.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga ma ei saa Ma ei tahaks kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Mõtleme natukene veel midagi.
Õpetaja: Siin City Change oleks kah nagu enamvähem, aga City Strop Town Citys Change Mulle Väga ei Meeldiks ikka see.
Õpetaja: No okei, ma. Mingid mõtteid avaldasid, et ma nagu kiidan, et te vähemalt enamvähem õigel teel olete, aga siis ma mõtlesin ka see on. See on jälle Potato Potato.
Õpetaja: Kuskil ei ole öeldud nagu mis mina ütlen. Nagu mingi muutuja nimi või mingi asi on Nagu mingi absoluutne tõde.
Õpetaja: Aga minule meeldiks midagi Taolist. Event New
Õpetaja: New City. Aga ma ei lisand ju New Citit. Vaata, et seda ei juhtunud,
Õpetaja: kui sa nüüd loeksid sellist asja nagu Tervikuna City Strop Town Ja event On event New City Selected
Õpetaja: Noh. Kui, see nagu, arvad Et nagu räägib selle loo ära, mis juhtus, siis See ongi see vastus.
Õpetaja: See võib isegi siia hetkel jääda, aga tegelikult ma tahan siia alla tagasi tulla ja öelda et, ee. Näed otse siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, et tuleks Event.
Õpetaja: Ah? Ta läks mitmele Reale Event New City Selected. Miks Ta bussis Nüüd kõik mitmele reale on lihtsalt see, et tal see joon tahtis natuke vastu tulla
Õpetaja: Ja õige ka sellepärast we are not Done Yet.
Õpetaja: Praegult on see, et tõesti ülesse. Läheb nagu sõnum.
Õpetaja: Me võime siin selle panna võrdlusmärgi ära. Vaata, Need pead kattuma omavahel.
Õpetaja: Käivita midagi. Vaata, ma ei tea, kas siin on mingi kirjaviga sees ma korra jaoks panen. Pasteiga üle.
Õpetaja: Ei ole.
Õpetaja: Nii on Niukene Event New City Selected,
Õpetaja: mis saama hakkab. Will deal with in a bit Nii, Nüüd teade läheb ülesse.
Õpetaja: Aga siin on nüüd üks probleem
Õpetaja: Meil ei Piisa ainult sellest sündmuse teadmisest, et midagi juhtus. Vaid Meil on nüüd vaja, midagi et ta.
Õpetaja: Ja me soovime andmeid. Meil on nüüd sõna Otseses mõttes tuvivärk.
Õpetaja: Event name Data Object. Ehk siis tähendab peale koma. Näete seda koma siin sees? Meil on vaja tegelikult siis panna midagi kaasa. Ka.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on midagi, mida teie, nagu tegelikult siin elusees ei saaks teada ega mõistatada. Nüüd on küsimus, et oota aga kuidas Ma saan kätte Option I väärtuse,
Õpetaja: sest et see välju siin Selected City Id on. Lihtsalt ütled? Vali üks optionitest, mille välju on see väärtus, et ma see pakk ei ole. Selected City Id. See ainult kontrollib Propsiga. Vaata, et mis nendest valikutest on valitud,
Õpetaja: kui ma valin midagi muud, siis selle väärtus taustal ei muutu ja ei saagi muutuda. Ta saaks ainult muutuda, kui ta oleks veemodel. Aga veemodel ei saa siin olla, sellepärast, et Props ei tohi kunagi siin
Õpetaja: selles failis kuidagi, nagu muutuda. Ta ei tohi muutuda. Siin ei saa olla ridagi koodi, mis Kuidagi muudaks muteeruks seda väärtust. Siin on öeldud ju ka. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Ee, Props ei tohi olla interaktiivselt seotud ühegi elemendiga, mis muudaks tema väärtust. Nii et see asi on praegu ainult selleks, et ole hea. Vali nendest optionitest. See value, mis number sul kattub selle väljuga, kui on null, siis on see, kui on mingi muu option, siis on vastav Option.
Õpetaja: Siis Kuidas nüüd saab kätte siiski sellelt selektilt? Aa, tema Niiöelda valitud. Ee, niiöelda valiku
Õpetaja: on selline, et meil ongi sündmus.
Õpetaja: See Change trigerdub ainult siis, kui on selle interaktiivse elemendiga mingi sündmus
Õpetaja: ja nüüd selle sündmuse käes. Sündmuse sees on meie info.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd kirjutame siia Event tegelt Dollari märk on ka vaja. Minu teada näete, See event.
Õpetaja: Ta tuleb automaatselt.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd kogu sündmus. See Nüüd on. See. On see klikk, Klik, klikk. See on event. Klikk on Event või no click Change. Mis iganes, Event.
Õpetaja: Või ütleme ad Change I puhul või ad kliki puhul Vahet pole, Vent on ikka Vent, Me saame Event ilt ka öelda, et. Hei, Event I küljest. Otsi ülesse atribuut. Otsi üles. On sõnaga target.
Õpetaja: Võta vend i küljest ja Nüüd on, mis atribuut väljub?
Õpetaja: Mis iganes Option valiti te selle event I küljes on see sama välju, mis valiti Nii,
Õpetaja: See nüüd on Selline süntaks, mis mängib kokku siis nagu mitmel tasandil. Esiteks,
Õpetaja: triggerdab siis jaoscript I sisese event i
Õpetaja: event I peale. Me ütleme, et käivita Voe meetod. Saada tuvi teele
Õpetaja: Pane kaasa sellele sündmusele niuke nimi ja paneb ka teele.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida ei tohi ära unustada, on see,
Õpetaja: et mis, Sest et see välju on meil antud hetkel numbrid. Aga välju võib Tekst ka olla. Üldjuhul ongi tekst või? Noh, saab olla tekst
Õpetaja: Ta vaikimisi. Läheb Tegelikult ikkagi Stringina.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga okei, las ta läheb praegult String ina. Saame seda vähemalt ühel hetkel vaadata nüüd, mis puudutab nagu seda koodi. Mis on selles siis see on?
Õpetaja: Meil on funktsioneeriv asi. Meil on, et sissetulevad. Ee, nende jaoks andmed mida kasutatakse optionite genereerimiseks. Meil on igal Optionil oma välju. Ja kõik linnad on null. Miks kõik linnad null on? Minu meelest
Õpetaja: on sellepärast et Esiteks, ta Natukene represseerib andmetüüpe, mis seal väljudes on? Ma võiks jätta siia tühjast ringi jättagi. Mingi stringi? Kas stringi nulli? Aga mis iganes aga mulle meeldib nagu null.
Õpetaja: Aa, Ja miks mulle see väärtus number null on see, et enamus ajast, kui meil on mingid või selektid, või mis Iganes seal taustal on andmebaasi. Need Aa väärtused.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja meie esimene rida algab alati numbrilt.
Õpetaja: Vastupidi, üks alati. Üks null on tema algväärtus, Millel teeb kohe plussplussi, kui ta võtab.
Õpetaja: Üks on alati esimene rida ja nüüd ongi hea. Vaata, et see siia siia, nendesse valikutesse, allapoole,
Õpetaja: Nagu kõik ülejäänud opsjonid, mis tulevad, tulevad andmebaasist. Ja kui me tavaliselt hoiame, siis nende välju sees Id, Sid,
Õpetaja: siis on garanteeritud et see Ei, Clash I kunagi ühegi teise.
Õpetaja: Id ga. Sellepärast null ei ole. Vähemalt võima võimalik ka muudes andmebaasides, kus vaikimisi. Võibolla alustab see, saab, et andmebaas hakkab pihta nagu nendest nullidega. Seal saab seadistada seda, et
Õpetaja: üks on esimene number, mis on üldse nagu olemas
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et Need on mingid imelikud andmebaasid ka. Nagu, kus on mingi null Nullist hakkab. See on nagu nii retardo. Nagu mingi tavainimene. Vaataks mingi nulli Seal,
Õpetaja: Oo, skandaal. Numbrid hakkavad ikka ühest, onju või Niigi? Oleme selles ma ei pääse. Vaata sellest, et paljud massiivid ja asjad alati hakkavad Indeksilt
Õpetaja: null. Stringi pikkus hakkab indeksilt null.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui sul on mingi tekst. Näiteks mis on esimene täht.
Õpetaja: Esimene täht on positsioonil. Null.
Õpetaja: Ee, Aga õnneks andmebaasis. Enamus tabelid ikka hakkavad. Nii et see on selles mõttes. Minu meelest päris hea asi, et siin on ka mingi numbriline väärtus. Kõik ise on ülejäänud numbrilised väärtused ja nulliga. Ma ei pea kunagi kartma. Vaata, et ee, et kui mina ütlen, et vali alg Alguses valik, null, et ta valib mingi muu linna kui kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Ja hiljem, kui me vaatame andmebaasi seal, kui ma näitan ühte lahendust, Kuidas filtreerimist saab väga cheepilt teha? Ee, siis siis. See null on jälle meie suur abimees.
Õpetaja: Nii sest et andme, sest ma ütlen andmebaasis, Ei ole kunagi väärtusega null, et ta on niuke. Turvaline Number saaks panna miinus üks ka, kui tahaks Neid numbreid, on ju veel
Õpetaja: onju Ee, kui tahaks.
Õpetaja: Ja siis saaks vaadata, et sul peab olema vähemalt siuke valik, mis on suurem kui näiteks kui tahad kontrollida midagi.
Õpetaja: Hea küll. Ee. Kütame, edasi
Õpetaja: aa. Nüüd, oleme siis seal maal kus, me oleme siin. Maal Et, meil on mingi event
Õpetaja: mis, peab Nüüd käivitama Mingisugust Aa sündmust.
Õpetaja: Teeme korra siia alla ka või? See on vaatamise koht korra. See, Kas seda Hello D on kasutatud praegult või ei ole ei ole, on ju? Me tuleme selle selle hello juurde. Tuleme tagasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, ma korra refaktoreerin. Ma panen Notify. Seda ei ole isegi vaja reflektureerida. Notify pärand.
Õpetaja: Ma panen Ma elu sees ei paneks Siukest. Meetod ei nimeta, aga ma lihtsalt muudan, ta nagu ümber. Las ta olla korra.
Õpetaja: No nüüd, ma tegin üle projekti. Ma pean korra vaatama, et midagi siin ei läinud
Õpetaja: nii, sest et võibolla Hello kuskil on sees. Aga miks peaks kuskil hello olema? Lihtsalt programmis. Meil sees ei peaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma nüüd. Mis meil nüüd on See, et nüüd On vaja hakata aru saama. Siin tuleb hästi natukene abstraktsiooni
Õpetaja: asjad mis koodis? Väga, lihtsalt ei peegeldu, aga on vaja teada,
Õpetaja: Ma saan jälle kirjutada siia mingit asja, kui ma tahan.
Õpetaja: Ma saan näiteks siia öelda Selected midagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Mida kuradit on valesti, et ta ei paku näiteks Electricity Id. D. Okei, ma pole selle lõpuni kirjutanud. Hea küll,
Õpetaja: ma saaks öelda, et. Ei, kui Ahkur. Ma ei taha seda niimoodi teha,
Õpetaja: Teeme korra ikka veel ühe uue Hello, Hello. Paneme Alert
Õpetaja: Ee, Selected. See on vaatamise koht. For Sure Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: See Nüüd viitab meetodile, mida pole veel olemas. Nüüd kopin selle nime ja lähen siia metsats blokki ja teen lihtsalt niukse meetodi.
Õpetaja: Alustame Step I Step onju.
Õpetaja: Nii kõigepealt alert.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, et vaatame, et. Kas. Kas see vent ise jõuab Barentisse Change I peale jõuab
Õpetaja: selle Noh, kordame kuidas see juhtub, kuna meile siin See saadab ka paki. Hetkel sellega midagi ei tee.
Õpetaja: See, kus me kutsume välja seda komponenti. Meil on pandud. Lissener See on kuulaja.
Õpetaja: Lühi niukse. Syntaxiga saab teha nagu ätt ja. Ja siis see nimi,
Õpetaja: kui tuleb alt selline sõnum käivitub meetod alert Selected City Id ja on Niukene. Aa, mis tuli ka?
Õpetaja: Müüd? Mida mina tahan, teha on see,
Õpetaja: et ma tahan saada tegelikult ikkagi kätte. Seda Pakikest on ju paugike.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida visuaalselt ei näe, mida ei näe, aga
Õpetaja: mida ei näe, aga saab ka nähtavaks teha, kui vaja,
Õpetaja: Ee Elusees ei tahaks seda kirjutada, Sest kui pole vaja, pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen siia sulud, siis siin saab sisse anda parameetreid.
Õpetaja: Hetkel ta Ütleb, et sul ei ole siin ühtegi parameetrit, on Nii
Õpetaja: kui mina teen siia ühe niiöelda sildikese ütlen näiteks Selected City
Õpetaja: Id Niukene. Niisugune Muutuja on lihtsalt Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Siia kirjutan ka valitud linna City Id.
Õpetaja: Kool on võrdub, on pluss ja panen siia Selected City Id
Õpetaja: Pluss on puudu Nii
Õpetaja: nüüd see meetod, mis siin üleval on just defineeritud. Nüüd ootab sisendit, on nii kuigi see on jaavas Gret
Õpetaja: ee, Selles mõttes, et ega ta käivituks ikka isegi annad või ei anna.
Õpetaja: Kui alt tuleb Event,
Õpetaja: siis mina saan selle Kogu Event i kogu Event I, Mis siit anti? Kogu Event I antud vaid anti event I target ja välju on nii?
Õpetaja: See tähendab, seda, et konkreetselt, lihtsalt mis Iganes valiku, mina valin sealt alt. Tuleb Siis niiöelda number. Ainult number tuleb
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kogu Event Siin ma saan kinni püüda ja uuesti kohe edasi anda, Nagu ma saaksin teha siia samamoodi
Õpetaja: dollari märgiga Avent, et alt tuleb mingisugune. See nüüd sümboliseerib Pakki
Õpetaja: Sõna Otseses mõttes pakkimist tuleb alt.
Õpetaja: See pak kukub mulle siia kasti Ja siin on muutujas Electricity Id
Õpetaja: Ja siin on teada valitud Tallinna City Id Midagi taolist. Nüüd vaatame, kas Kas see tõesti töötab niimoodi,
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan. Refresh.
Õpetaja: Ma olin Tallinn tuli valitud linna. City Id on nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd niimoodi See asi käitub, aga meil on nüüd üks väikene mugavus. Asi, mis on teie jaoks selles mõttes abstraktsioon? Näete, kogu see osa siin.
Õpetaja: Seda Ei ole vaja kirjutada, vaid see toimub seal taustal. Nii või naa.
Õpetaja: Ehk kui meil on mingi Event, millega tuleb pakk ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me nüüd siin Listeneris käivitame mingisuguse meetodi, Siis see pakk pannakse kaasa
Õpetaja: esimesel kohal siia meetodisse sisse, kaasa vaikimisi,
Õpetaja: ehk siis, kui siin Mul on, ee, niiöelda olemas. Muutuja Selected City Id Siis ta püüab selle kinni.
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb see koodis. Seda kuidagi ei näe, on ju Ei, Näe, sa pead panema mitu asja ise kokku, et saad aru, mis toimub. Sa Pead olema teadlik, et emit saadab lisaks sõnumile ka paki
Õpetaja: Ja täpsemalt, mille selle sündmuse välju, Mis iganes opsion valiti. See on lihtsalt süntaks, mis toob pähe õppida.
Õpetaja: Siin on kuulaja käivitatakse meetod, mis on siin selles Atms Views ja see pakk tuleb automaatselt parameetrina. Kaasa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame, kas töötab Refresh Tallinn tuli. See väärtus. Sinna
Õpetaja: tuleb see Pakt tuleb sellele meetodile kaasa. Mida Event käivitab?
Õpetaja: Nüüd Väikene ohukoht
Õpetaja: Kogu aeg mõnes Kohas Kutsume meetodeid välja niimoodi et ei pea kasutama neid Ee, sulge Mõnes kohas mitte. Vaadake, mis juhtub siis, kui ma panen sulud. Lihtsalt see nii sama, mis nüüd juhtub, on see, et
Õpetaja: kaasa ei lähe ühtegi parameetrit. Võimekus on olemas siin sellel Selected City Id, Aga tegelikult. Mis me saadame niipea kui need paned need tühjad Ee, Niiöelda, ee.
Õpetaja: Noh, mitte jutumärgid. Sulud siis sinna Alla Läheb justkui tühjus,
Õpetaja: et nüüd on nagu see, et ma tahan midagi saata, aga ma Ei, ma ei saada midagi. Siis ta täpselt seda teeb. Noh, vaatame, mis juhtub. Tere, Fresh
Õpetaja: Tulen, valin jälle. Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Näete, nüüd tuli Underfind ei tulnud all Defineerimata Sa ei pannudki midagi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaksin nalli panna. Ma võin siia nal panna. Näiteks nal.
Õpetaja: Noh, see oleks null, Aga seal on nagu, et pole pole Öeldud
Õpetaja: Pole öeldud, mis tuleb nagu põhimõtteliselt on nagu mis asi on pole määratud, mis asi see on?
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb nal onju? Nal on ka asi
Õpetaja: tühjus. Again, et siin niukse asjaga tuleb olla ettevaatlik.
Õpetaja: Seda ei tohi panna, nagu ma Olen ise kuskil ühtlustanud, et. Ah, Teen kõike ühte stiili ja ei saanud aru,
Õpetaja: millised niiöelda efektid on selle peale nii nüüd,
Õpetaja: mis on Nüüd nagu probleem on see.
Õpetaja: Ma panen selle Selected City Id väärtuseks nulli,
Õpetaja: et ma soovin, niimoodi et kui me lehte laeme Selected City Id. Väärtus on Null. City D tuuakse kõik ära. Nii, siis anname kõik need linnad ja anname selle, et vali mulle valik. Üks põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: See kõik tuleb kenasti siia. Ee, kuna siin on see
Õpetaja: olemas, siis see valitakse nende seast. Seal, kus See, väljuv kattub nulliga, mis on Kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: No vaatame. Lähme, Refresh.
Õpetaja: Noh, ongi kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Kui ma valin mingisuguse muu linna Tartu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nüüd siis selline. Okei, praegu Ta veel isegi kattub. Vaata, see on. Ee, Fine. Vaata, ee.
Õpetaja: Jah, meie. Ta see visuaalselt on. Tartu, Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: On Tartu
Õpetaja: siis koodi mõttes. Tegelikult peaks siin olema niimoodi, et on, valitud see valik, mis on Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis peaks olema see väärtus, mis seal Niiöelda on,
Õpetaja: kui me vaatame nüüd voest selle sisu. Ma teen korra, Refresh. I ära vaatame seda niimoodi. Step by step,
Õpetaja: ee Võtan. Selle Voe tööriista. Vaatame, et. Hei, mis on hetkel
Õpetaja: väärtus? Selected City Id on null
Õpetaja: ja siin on kõik linnad valitud. Praegu klapib, onju nii? Kõik on fine.
Õpetaja: Kui ma valin siit Tartu valitud linna City Id on kolm väga tore.
Õpetaja: Visuaalselt on tartu.
Õpetaja: Kui ma klikin isegi kuskile, mujale. Klikin ikka seda. City Strop Town Is siis selected City Id On endiselt null
Õpetaja: aga, Nüüd Tegelikult on ju mismatch Tegelikult on mis, Much,
Õpetaja: et visuaalses pooles visuaalne pool ei lähe enam andmetega kokku.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on selline asi, et ee, me ei tohi muuta seda Selected City Id väärtust. Seal ei tohi olla interaktiivselt seotud ega midagi. Me peame tegema nüüd niukse tobeda. Flow.
Õpetaja: Täpselt Nii see käibki. Komposition Up is On See natukene paari sõnaga ära automatiseeritud, aga taustal on täpselt sama asi.
Õpetaja: See käib niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Noh, Propsiga ujub sulle mingi väärtus siia. Alla sisse.
Õpetaja: Kui sa soovid, et Propsi väärtus muutuks, et tuleks uus väärtus,
Õpetaja: siis sa pead tegema niimoodi, et sa miit iga saadad ülesse, teate,
Õpetaja: mis muudaks ära niiöelda selle sisseantava objekti väärtuse mis nagu voolab propsina alla tagasi sisse. Propsi väärtust saavad muuta ainult pärandist.
Õpetaja: Ja seal on Siis selline Flow. Iga kord, et sa pead mikk ima ülesse, et muuda ära minu väärtus. Kas te saate sellest mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: et me ei saa proppsi seal selles Childis kuidagi muuta.
Õpetaja: Aga kui on põhjus, et see peab muutuma, siis see saab alati olla niimoodi, et sa Saadad lihtsalt barentile. Teate, midagi juhtus. Ja nüüd peavad andmed muutuma.
Õpetaja: Me tahame põhimõtteliselt teha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No see on nüüd kaasategemise koht selles mõttes Nagu, nagu andmed
Õpetaja: ringleks kaks korda, et kõigepealt ma muudangi seda. Ee,
Õpetaja: sa oled. Sa põhimõtteliselt tabasid seda, Mis sa praegu ütlesid, et Andmed muutuvad kaks korda. Ma vaatan korra, kas mul
Õpetaja: pilte on Kuskil. Aa, siin.
Õpetaja: Seda pilti pole. Ma vanasti joonistasin, aga need olid väga kohutavad Pildid Ma korra vaatan, Kas kuskil on mul midagi veel tehtud Ee. Seda Flow ka.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, ma korra peast tulistan seda, ma Vaatan lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Mulle tundub, et siit juba siit maalt juba saavad. Nagu mingid niuksed asjad otsa.
Õpetaja: No tule lahti. Vaata, mis see Feb üksteist On Äkki siin midagi? On? Ma kunagi olen joonistanud neid pilte. Äkki enne nägi enne, Aga ma ei tahaks enam neid joonistada.
Õpetaja: Mm, läheb süda pahaks. Kui ma pean joonistama jälle, et huviga läheb ülesse
Õpetaja: Andmed muutusid, muuda andmeid, pärand muudab andmeid. Ja siis ma saadan ülesse uued muudetud andmed
Õpetaja: Teeme, teeme selle, teeme selle koodi lõpuni ja siis ütleme korra. Cloud, ile et teeks meile väikse skeemi Olete nõus,
Õpetaja: et siis See Muutub visuaalseks. Vaata, et see Full Circle
Õpetaja: nüüd see. Kas teil see on kir? Mis te. Kas teil midagi on kirjutatud või ei ole siin. Praegu nii. Teil jutumärki Kirjutage. Mina refaktureerin. Teie kirjutage. Lihtsalt kirjutage Set
Õpetaja: Selected City Id
Õpetaja: ja mina ütlen refaktor. Te lihtsalt kirjutasite Niukse meetod oli, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd te tulete alla meetodi bloki.
Õpetaja: Otsite siit natuke vaba ruumi meetodit Seal kirjutate, Siis võtate, Kui te juba midagi Otsite Selected City ja It sulud
Õpetaja: sul. Kui te sisse kirjutate. See Electric City Id. No te kirjutate seda sama koodi, välja arvatud seda Alert I. Loomulikult pole vaja. Kirjutage see asi valmis ja siis ma räägin edasi.
Õpetaja: Nii?
Õpetaja: Kas jaavast? Selline asi meenutab midagi, mis? Mis kuradi Mis Mis meetodit see meenutab?
Õpetaja: Paneme uue kandme sisse.
Õpetaja: Setter. Noh, see ongi see jaavas on? Objekti väljad, mingi first name ja last name. Need on Private.
Õpetaja: Neid ei ole võimalik. Näiteks, et sul on objekt olemas. Aa, aa niiöelda student.
Õpetaja: Sul on muutuja on student. Sa ei saa öelda, seal Student, punkt ja anna mingi uus väärtus. Sa saad teha niimoodi. Student punkt Set First Name.
Õpetaja: Käivitad meetodi, Viskad sinna, sisse, Näiteks mingi nime Rain. Ja palun väga,
Õpetaja: see on setter meetod, et ongi setter meetod. See nüüd lihtsalt eeldab seda, et meil kandja nagu võib tuua objekt orienteeritud programmeerimist jaavat, et näed. Siin ongi meil objektid. See ongi meie objekti. Väli
Õpetaja: Data blokk on meie kogu objekti väli
Õpetaja: Set Selected City Id peaks andma sellele uue väärtuse vastavalt sellele, mis sisse tuleb.
Õpetaja: Nii, noh, nüüd on siis vaja ainult ära progeda, see on väga lihtne selle väärtusega, mis tuleb sisse Selector City Id.
Õpetaja: Mis me siis kirjutame?
Õpetaja: See on setter meetod sellele väljale.
Õpetaja: No okei, selle No Ei, no võib alustada. Aga Ei, no vaatame. No mis edasi, mis edasi?
Õpetaja: Aga see ei ole. Jaava.
Õpetaja: See See ei ole jal, Temal ei ole siin. Me puudutame otse välja, sest meil ei ole. Nagu see ongi settermeetod. See on settermeetod. Sellele väljale
Õpetaja: see mis tuleb siia ümbriku sisse. Peab minema siia ümbriku sisse. See on missioon. See on maailma kõige lihtsam missioon üldse.
Õpetaja: Mis? No set s electricity Id on meetodi nimi, mis ma just kirjutasin.
Õpetaja: Vot nüüd hakkab pihta.
Õpetaja: Me räägime nagu javas on täpselt samamoodi. This, Minge vaadake ühte klassi, Kus on set. Pange ette ja küsige. Java seter meetodit. Kas me juba tegime korra ka seda?
Õpetaja: Seal on väljad, First name, last name üleval Klassis on first name, last, name. Meil on meetod Set. First, name, set, first Name. Võtab sisse. Stringi. First, name, mis ta teeb, Ütleb,
Õpetaja: First. Name võrdub See This punkt. Selected City Id võrdub Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Kas see, et need kaks on valged?
Õpetaja: Kas see on lilla?
Õpetaja: Noh, anna sellele sissetulev väärtus. Ei midagi, Fancy.
Õpetaja: Nii, proovime siis. Aa, nüüd.
Õpetaja: Aa, et. Aa. Ütleme, et siis Cloud teeks meile siin natuke on õppematerjali Minu jaoks. On see flow, on selge. Ja ma olen joonistanud neid pilte ja asju ka,
Õpetaja: aga enam ma ei ma ei taha.
Õpetaja: See võtab aega lihtsalt muud midagi. Vaatame, äkki saame odavamalt. Ma ütlen, et ee. Ole hea
Õpetaja: ja paneme seda ka. Ee, kriips, Ee
Õpetaja: Skill loo uus õppematerjal pand ühikuga. Ee, T üks õppematerjal.
Õpetaja: Ee, voe ee, pärand to child
Õpetaja: child to parent.
Õpetaja: Noh, ega see jätkub pärand To Child Flow kohta.
Õpetaja: Tee ka mingi diagramm.
Õpetaja: Näitena Vaatleme koodi.
Õpetaja: Vaatame Ee, pärand komponenti.
Õpetaja: Oo oponenti.
Õpetaja: Noh, näed, tulen. Võtan siit selle parem Klõps reference. Ja lihtsalt see rada. Source Views, Atms View. See on pärand
Õpetaja: ja Child
Õpetaja: Nii Copy reference.
Õpetaja: Võibolla siia ka siis kuulan nii,
Õpetaja: Ee, soovime vaadelda
Õpetaja: Child Ropsi.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis Props I. Me soovime jälgida seda.
Õpetaja: Soovime vaadelda Childpropsi
Õpetaja: väärtuse muutumist alates sellest hetkest, kui vaade laetakse Ja kasutaja.
Õpetaja: Kuni kuni selleni, et kasutaja
Õpetaja: valib
Õpetaja: Select menüüst mingi teise linna.
Õpetaja: Kui algne linn.
Õpetaja: Noh, saab aru küll.
Õpetaja: Tema jaoks ei tohiks ju midagi erilist olla, Aga lihtsalt vaatame, kuidas tema sellega hakkama saab.
Õpetaja: Aa, sest õppematerjale peame alles ka, onju?
Õpetaja: Jälle Saate vaadata. Teil on Nii palju. Teil on juba neid materjale, mida me oleme ise küsinud. Teil on.
Õpetaja: Teil on videod. Teil on Cloud arvutisse installitud, kellel on Subscription olemas. Käsi püsti.
Õpetaja: Olete juba midagi kirjutanud ka, null, Aga noh, sa oled midagi, mis sa kirjutasid?
Õpetaja: Küsisin mingit asja, mida tähendab kuidas Aega saaks subskripsida juurde.
Õpetaja: Aega kirjutas seda talle vä? Ei, ta kirjutab selle. Mida vähem sa pole, Kirjutad seda rohkem sul on,
Õpetaja: Ee, et Ee, ja, no. On aeg, et on aeg hakata lugema neid materjale. On aeg hakata vestlema
Õpetaja: ja pange ka ise samamoodi. Kaldkriips kill ohus õppematerjal päev ja kirjuta nagu et näed, loen siit midagi.
Õpetaja: Tahaks selle asja kohta rohkem teada, et seal on ju ära tal skill, is öeldud, et tee seda Alga. Sõbralikud lisanäiteid ja analooge. Analoogid on suht Capital olnud. Minu Meelest
Õpetaja: ee, vaatame siis. Refresh toob kohe välja unversion Files. Topelt, klõps,
Õpetaja: F neli. Lähme faili. Vaatame seda preview vaatest. Vaatame, mis ta räägib.
Õpetaja: Komponent. Andmevoog. Mis See on
Õpetaja: voerakenduses? Sa jagad koodi Komponentideks. Nagu legoklotse. Iga komponent teeb ühte asja hästi, aga komponendid peavad omavahel suhtlema. Pärend vanem. Annab andmed halda chilt, laps saab need kätte Chilt teavitab pärendit. Kui midagi juhtub, pärend reageerib. See on voe põhiline andmevaemuste Props alla sündmust üles
Õpetaja: Abc, sest ma arvan, et see ei Ole ainult vaem, aga võiks küsida, kuidas reaktivis on.
Õpetaja: Päriselust analoogia. Kujutle, et oled restorani omanik. Pärand. Sul on Kelner Child. Oh, kui halb suhe. Kunagi. Ärge töötage ühes ettevõttes koos Bad idea.
Õpetaja: Sina annad kelnerile menüü Prop Citys ja ütle, et milline linn on hetkel Valitud Prop Selected City Id
Õpetaja: menüü. Hetkevalik kelner näitab seda kliendile. Kui klient valib, uue linna. Kelner teatab sulle
Õpetaja: Event New City Selected. Sina uuendad oma andmeid ja annad kelnerile uue info. Mm,
Õpetaja: kelner ei muuda ise menüüd. Ta ainu kuvab ja teavitab täpselt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame meie näidata, mis juubel City Strop. Ta on pärand Child
Õpetaja: Ee, pärandlõhendatult. City Strop Town Prop Alla linna nimekiri
Õpetaja: propo alla valitud linna id Event Kuulad. Said sündmust Üles on siinkohal küsimusi.
Õpetaja: No loodan, et ei ole.
Õpetaja: Script.
Õpetaja: Algväärtus, null. Kõik linnad, null. Filter puudub. Kõik linnad. Esimene valik, Vaata, algväärtus, kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Ee, meetod. Ee, siin on siis see pärand uuendab oma andmeid.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ta siin toob iga rea kohta põhimõtteliselt ee. Kõik ära, et Saate seda vaadata pärast ka veel natuke pikemalt.
Õpetaja: Ee, Child Lühendatult
Õpetaja: välju. Ta on muud asjad ära võtnud. Onju, et välju, mis on valitud Mis see miit Ib onju?
Õpetaja: Props saab parentilt
Õpetaja: täielik andmevoo diagramm. No nüüd saab olema põnev. Kuidas ta siis seda nagu kavatseb Nagu teha? Vaata, järgnev diagramm näitab Select City teekonda alates lehe laadimisest, kuni selle hetkeni, et kasutaja valib uue linna faas. Üks vaade laetakse Before
Õpetaja: algväärtus, Kõik linnad, Ee, tühi server pole vastanud. Before Mount käivitub Get Cities käivitatakse Htt päring serverisse. Server saadab sõnumi Vastus. Tuleb Noh, City üks Tallinn Tartu Pär. No Teate küll, kõik need linnad tulevad
Õpetaja: nüüd. Pärand ikka. See on Atm. Su pärend
Õpetaja: saab uued andmed. Data uuendatud Selected City. Id on Null. Citys on massiiv tallinntartu pärnu. Mida iganes faas. Kaks pärend saadab Props alla Childile.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on Atm Spärrend Citys Props voolab alla.
Õpetaja: Selected City Id voolavad alla. Nüüd City Strop Down saab kätte. Propsina need linnad.
Õpetaja: Selected City Id Väärtus Null, onju? Need Voolavad alla.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Selected Value on null, mis tähendab seda, et kõik linnad on valitud. Tallinntartu ei ole valitud, on arusaadav siiamaani faas. Kolm Nüüd hakkab, siis see, mis juhtub, kui kasutaja siin tuleb. Nüüd see ringi värk veel. Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Kasutaja valib Tartu
Õpetaja: Ee Kasutaja klikib. Tartus Change sündmus käivitub. Event Target. Value väärtus on. Kaks. Näed, String Ina by the way string Ina
Õpetaja: Limit läheb Ülesse
Õpetaja: koosväärtusega string. Kaks. Peame sellega ka Tegelema Sündmus läheb üles Barentile. No, siin nool on. Alla. Aga te peate mõttest aru saama.
Õpetaja: Nüüd pärand saab selle sündmuse selle kuulajaga kätte.
Õpetaja: Mida ta teeb? Ta käivitab meetodi mis on siin samas set Selected City Id väärtusega String Kaks
Õpetaja: ja siis all selles meetodis Öeldakse, et City Id võrdub kaks barent uuendab oma andmeid, on nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme edasi. Nüüd läheb. Ee. Jah, nüüd parend Barend uuendab, saadab uuendatab propi uuesti alla.
Õpetaja: Mis sest et visuaalselt tegelikult. Seal on juba see. Ee, muutus Toimund. Vaata, et ee Kõik linnade asemel näeme, mis Meil Siin on Tartu vä.
Õpetaja: Mida iganes, Aa, et mis? Sest et see on muutnud. Aga tegelikult, vaata, idee on see, et ega need Andmed peavad olema kooskõlas visuaaliga.
Õpetaja: Selected City It uuendatud propoola Alla City Strop Town Saab selle kätte propsis. Tuleb väärtus selected. City Id On Kaks uus väärtus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Select Välju võrdub kaks, Mis tähendab, Tartu on nüüd valitud.
Õpetaja: Vot nii lühike kokkuvõte ost. Oo, mulle meeldib, sest need On Ajajoon pärend Citys kuvab linnad,
Õpetaja: kuvab Tallinn Tall. Kõik linnad. Valituna. Kasutaja valib tartu Nüüd lähevad sündmused. Vaata, see on hästi natuke Nihkes. Onju? Childist läheb ja koos väärtusega. Kaks
Õpetaja: käivitatakse meetod Z Electricity Id. Kaks saab selle väärtuse, on ju? Ja nüüd Props Ina Propsina läheb see alla
Õpetaja: tagasi.
Õpetaja: Reegel Child ei muuda kunagi Prop I otse Ta ainult Emiit Ib sündmuse ja ootab, et pärandprop I uuendaks. Miks, Nii, Miks mitte Child muudab ise? Miks pärand muudel?
Õpetaja: Andmed oleksid kahes kohas? Parent a child.
Õpetaja: Üks tõeallikas. Ainult pärend.
Õpetaja: Kui seal oleks eraldi muutuja, mis Ei, voolaks sisse, vaid me peaks kuidagi programmiliselt sida ise kuidagi haldama. Vaata, siis juhtubki seda, et meil võib olla erinevad andmed
Õpetaja: ja Childis. Aga need peavad olla samad Raske jälgida, mis muutus?
Õpetaja: Muutused on nähtavad ja jälgitavad sellepärast, et see on
Õpetaja: teised komponendid, ei tea muututest muutustest. See. See ei ole child. Il vajalik. See nagu andmeid saadab ise teistele.
Õpetaja: Voe hoiatab mutatsiooni eest Miks pä. Siin on põhjused? Nagu Vahet pole, see peab nii olema
Õpetaja: Prop andmed, mida saab saada Nak I sinna juba, bla, bla, bla.
Õpetaja: Okei, see. See ei ole lihtne Flow. Aga see peab nii olema.
Õpetaja: See peab nii olema lihtsalt sellepärast, et see tehnoloogia on selliselt üles ehitatud.
Õpetaja: Nii lihtne see ongi. Ma Küsin ühe küsimuse otsa. Mingit õppematerjali ei vaja. Aga ma küsin, et ee,
Õpetaja: kas teistes ee tehnoloogiates on sarnased põhimõtted.
Õpetaja: No ma oleks võinud öelda. Muidugi, Reakt ja angular. Veidi kahetsen, et ei öelnud, aga. No vaata, mis ta vastab.
Õpetaja: Aga selle ma lükkan siia ära.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: ee, Vaatame jah, sama musteriseb pea kõikjal. Projekt. Peaaegu Identne. Lihtsalt erinev süntaks. No Ma ei hakka isegi vaatama
Õpetaja: Angular Props alla, sündmused üles aut, Struktuuris. Identne poeg. Ainult Dekora süntaks erineb lihtsalt props alla. Sündmused ülesse
Õpetaja: väljaspool Frontend I Android Gotlin.
Õpetaja: Jah, näed, siin on mõlemad asjad. Vaata, Props alla. Mitu üles ja nende analoogiad
Õpetaja: üldine hoop konstruktori argument. Okei, see on midagi muud.
Õpetaja: Saime vist oma vastuse. Vaata, et selline ongi See Flow. Lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: See on see Flow.
Õpetaja: Me ei saa Propse muuta sellepärast, et meil on Niuke reaktiivne süsteem,
Õpetaja: et on ainult ühes kohas mingisugused väärtused. Ja sa hoolitsed nende andmete eest.
Õpetaja: Ülejäänud asi ise alla, ülevalt alla nägu kask.
Õpetaja: Kas kogu see ideoloogia? Vaata, et mis ma Olen rääkinud nagu, et vo andmed voolavad ülevalt alla. Kas see hakkab kuidagi vaikselt nagu klikkima? Vaata, et nagu. Mis. Mis see mõte nagu siin taga on? On ju,
Õpetaja: et et siin on Niukene ülesehitus ja andmed tulevad ülevalt alla. Oleks väga segane algus, Mis ülevalt alla Mida See tähendab, mis asja tähendab andmed vool ülevalt alla. See on Niuke Rutiinflow. Lihtsalt et kõik vajalikud asjad joonistatakse andmete pealt,
Õpetaja: ja ainuke nagu Ainukene mure ongi meil muretseda Lihtsalt, et seal selles õiges kohas, kus on õiged andmed.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal me teeme õigeid muudatusi õigel hetkel
Õpetaja: ja Ülejäänud. Asjad lihtsalt nagu maagilised iseenesest loksuvad paika.
Õpetaja: Okei, davai.
Õpetaja: Noh, viimased ponnistused. Mul meil siin midagi täna veel teha
Õpetaja: on Aa, suures pildis on nüüd korrektne, Välja arvatud seda, et nagu me nägime, et tegelikult
Õpetaja: on väikene mure siiski sees.
Õpetaja: No see on õnneks hästi lihtne Lahendus pole mitte midagi keerulist.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma teen lahti. Selle Voe tööriista. Teeme lahti. Citystrop Town I
Õpetaja: Selected City Id Väärtus On alguses null
Õpetaja: aga, Kui ma muudan selle tallinnaks, mis ta nüüd on?
Õpetaja: Mis on nagu. Mis nende kahe vahel? Nagu, No nüüd on isegi sellega jama vaata ka.
Õpetaja: Tere, Refresh. Vaadake lihtsalt värvi.
Õpetaja: Teen korra selle lahti. On null
Õpetaja: Nii, kui ma valin siit, tallinn
Õpetaja: ma korra klikin mujale, mul oli see asi siin lahti.
Õpetaja: Noh, Tartu, mis temaga on, on String.
Õpetaja: Sõnad on String. Ärme sõna ütle. Ütle String,
Õpetaja: kust sulle rohkem meeldib sõna Või strengit.
Õpetaja: Ausalt öeldes, mulle meeldib. Meeldib vä.
Õpetaja: Aga vaata, et seda oma rüpe raali täna koju ei unusta.
Õpetaja: Laptop.
Õpetaja: Jah, sulle meeldib kas trening.
Õpetaja: Noh, jah, Davai, See on väga ilus küll. Ja ma ei tea. Ei või öelda sülearvutikeskuse või raal
Õpetaja: õudne Ee, See, koht, kus Me Saadame esimene võimalus, kus meil on võimalik asi teha numbriks. Meil on neid mitmeid kohti.
Õpetaja: Me saame põhimõtteliselt siin öelda. Et näed, ma teen. Ärge tehke number
Õpetaja: sulud. Ma saaks siin teha seda numbriks. See on see, et võta sisse eni Control B. Mina teen
Õpetaja: numbriks. On ju. Aga miks seda teha nii hilises etapis? Siis kui ma progen seda siin ja teinekord kasutan seda kuskil mujal. Ma pean seda uuesti programmeerima. Pigem on, nagu, et see asi siin
Õpetaja: nii number.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui kui seda liigutust teete, siis teda on lihtsam alati niimoodi teha. Võtke see asi korra niimoodi Katiga Mällu Kontroll X.
Õpetaja: Kirjutage number tab.
Õpetaja: Aa, sulud ja pange lihtsalt tagasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see, et enne kui see Asi läheb teele.
Õpetaja: See tehakse numbriks ja kogu pak läheb juba ülesse nagu normaalselt.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd kui me vaatame seda lahendust,
Õpetaja: Ee, ma arvan, et me teeme siia et jääb niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, work in progress. Ma ei tea, kas siit tuleb või midagi või mitte, aga ma teen, Kui mitte ainult Bush, aga seda bussi ma ootama ei jää. Nagu
Õpetaja: Ee pea, et seal komitee ära teeb.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: Ma tahan nüüd teha seda koodi näidata. Alternatiivi. Ja see tuleb mängu siis, kui meil see asi natukene siin läheb kuidagi pikaks
Õpetaja: või keeruliseks või tahaks üle mitme rea kirjutada, et see sama ad Change, mis teeb siin kogu selle osa Niimoodi
Õpetaja: saab tegelikult teha eraldi meetodiga.
Õpetaja: Näiteks, ee.
Õpetaja: Mina panen selle Meetodi nimeks. Ma Ütlen, et seda ei ole vaja. Update Selected City, Id
Õpetaja: Update Selected City Id Nüüd Mina tahan teha samasuguse miti Emit,
Õpetaja: Ahah, Define. Mits seda ka võiks teha? Ee, ei kirjutanud. Siin peab kirjutama Disc ka, Sest et ma kirjutan Scriptis
Õpetaja: This a meat.
Õpetaja: Nii, Nüüd see sisu tuleb siia selles osas sama.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on küsimus, et mul on ju vaja seda asja. Seda Event I.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma Tahan seda sama asja Ee, niiöelda panna siia.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on nagu see, et temal on küsimus, Mis asi see veel on, Mis asi See vent on nagu, on ju
Õpetaja: Ja sa.
Õpetaja: Ma pean selle kaasa panema. Vaata, see konks on see, et kui sa selle meetodi käivitad, Siis sa pead tegema niimoodi, et kas sa. Ma näitan korra? Hakkame nüüd tegema seda väljakutsumist Ma veel. Ma veel. Ma jätan hetkel selle Küsimärgi, onju? Pakk peab minema. See on eesmärk.
Õpetaja: Kogu see asi nüüd on, niimoodi et Change käivitab. Kas seda, mis me siia kirjutasime,
Õpetaja: või Kui ma nüüd ütlen, et kuule update Selected City Id,
Õpetaja: see Nüüd käivitab siis selle meetodi, mis on siin all,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd on jälle See meetod ei tea oma elust väljaspoolsest, elust, ööd ega mütsi.
Õpetaja: Kogu kogu informatsioon, mida sa vajad siin siis tuleb panna kaasa. Jah, ma saan. Lä ligi sellele City sele. Ma saan ligi sellele Selected City Id Le. Aga see Selected City idee on see, mis ülevalt sisse voolab. See ei muutu kunagi. Ju
Õpetaja: see. See. Kogu see kogu muusika ongi see, et siin teha, siis on see, et see koht, kus ma selle meetodi välja kutsun. Updates Electric City Id.
Õpetaja: Ma pean tegema, et kui sa selle meetodi välja kutsud, et siin on olemas, siis Näiteks Event, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd. Aa. Me saame proovida. Minu meelest vaikimisi läheb Event kaasa. Ma ei ole. Kindel Me saame proovida
Õpetaja: kas läheb või ei lähe. Kas see töötab või ei tööta, saab kohe ära näha. Event, Siin on ikka samamoodi target
Õpetaja: punkt, value.
Õpetaja: Aa see, et Ta läheks numbrina Control Iks ja ütlen number.
Õpetaja: Panen siia. Sisse
Õpetaja: Ee, lihtsalt. Ma ei mäleta. Kas ma pean tegema niimoodi, et ma ütlen Event siin nagu et Anna vend kaasa
Õpetaja: või ei pea. No ma proovin. Esialgu niimoodi? Kuidas Ma tean, et ta kindlalt töötab.
Õpetaja: Noh, vaatan
Õpetaja: Ee, siin jälle. Saan ju vaadata, onju? Teen lahti Atm City. Kas ta voolab tagasi või Mitte Selected City Id on null. Valin Tartu
Õpetaja: Tuli kolm ja numbrina Ka Onju töötas. Nüüd saab proovida. Vaata, et see peab siia jääma, et me, Noh, mul, kui mul ei ole silti, siis mul on siin. Nagu. Et millest ma räägin, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui mul seda siin nagu ei oleks, siis mul oleks nagu küsimus, et. Vau, kus ma siis nagu midagi saan? Silti pole Silt peab olema, Aga ma arvan, et süntaksi mõttes. Ee, et kui mul siin midagi pole ma nüüd. Võibolla peangi need sulud ära kustutama. Ma ei tea, kohe proovime. Teeme Refresh
Õpetaja: peast. Ei mäleta niukseid. Asju lähme Vaatame. Kõigepealt Algseisu on null. Valin Tartu ei tulnud,
Õpetaja: onju? Võin korra klikkida mujale, et lihtsalt vaadata refresh is ju pole. Ma pakun, et kui selle ära võtta,
Õpetaja: siis võibolla ta töötab. Võibolla ma ei ole kindel.
Õpetaja: Aa, siin on nii palju kohti. Vaata, kus on nagu mingit niukest ee, Fookuspookust ja abstraktsiooni, Et me lihtsalt ei jaksa meeles hoida
Õpetaja: tuli Ma nägin, et juba tuli,
Õpetaja: et ma ei pea seda kirjutama välja, et Kui mingi Change käib, ju sa selle event iga. Soovid midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Kui sa käivitad mingi meetodi. See vahe lihtsalt on see, et kogu See asi tegelikult mahtus väga edukalt ära. Siia, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: No, siin on Dollari. Märk on puudu. Vaata, et siin Syntaxis peab olema Niimoodi ka on nii?
Õpetaja: Mul on veel valikud. Ma teen tagasi. Vaata selle, et. Okei, Ma tahan ikkagi midagi kaasa anda, aga ma siin ei taha tervet Event i vaid tahan juba seda. Ee, siit juba tahaks. Vaata niimoodi, et panen muuto nimeks
Õpetaja: City Id.
Õpetaja: Siin juba panen kaasa kogu asja Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Aga siis on see, et siin väljakutsumis hetkel ma pean ikkagi ütlema event
Õpetaja: ma saaksin selle kätte event Punkt
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis oli veel? Ee, target punkt.
Õpetaja: Value.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga ta läheb stringina. Noh, võibolla ma selle teeksin siin naabriks. Aga Võibolla sa. Ma Saan siin ka teha ju? Vaata, mis ma teen. Kontrolliks
Õpetaja: number.
Õpetaja: Noh, töötaks Jah,
Õpetaja: Siit update Selected City Id numbrina Anna kaasa Event Ist. Ainult see Selected City Id, mitte Event I Ennast
Õpetaja: peaks ka töötama Loogika. Vähemalt ütleks, et peaks töötama.
Õpetaja: Null on Muudan ära. Tartu on kolm. Töötab, et neid lähenemisi on igasuguseid. Või siis saaks tõesti teha, niimoodi. Et Davai. Las siis läheb kaasa.
Õpetaja: Ee noh, ma ei tea, Siis nagu veits tobe, Nagu et Okei, annan siis ikkagi selle. Selected City it Siit. Ta läheb String Ina aga lõpptulemus läheb ikkagi Nabrina,
Õpetaja: midagi ei ole muutunud. Vaata, lihtsalt. Mina arvan, et me lepime kokku, et kui me saame teha asju niimoodi, enamvähem oneline Il ja Meile tundub, et on loetav ja arusaadav. Lihtne mingi.
Õpetaja: Siis Me ei hakka tegema eraldi meetodi blokki ja meetodit sellepärast.
Õpetaja: Ah, kurat, nüüd on see vale asi. Ma lihtsalt taastan selle, mis oli komiteega põmm.
Õpetaja: Et saate aru, et kui on Kui saab aru, mis toimub ja Niukene lühikene asi, siis me ei hakka eraldi meetodit selle jaoks tegema,
Õpetaja: kui juba läheb. Action Iks nagu päris Action Iks et on natukene rohkem vaja siin tegevustega toimetada ja midagi teha. No siis on abistaja. Siis me teeme lihtsalt abimeetodi sinna alla ja kutsume välja. Seda
Õpetaja: Me teeme seda niimoodi tunde järgi. Kuidas me hindame koodi loetavust?
Õpetaja: Sest ega me nagu väga neid meetodeid juurde ei taha teha ka kogu aeg
Õpetaja: rohkem kooli hüppa ülesse alla Sest et see on vahe. Vaata, see on nagu sa. Sa pead seda nagu hindama nagu mõtlema, nagu seda. Ma Lähen korra siia. Ära vaata, onju? Tagasi Kus siin on? Kus on see event, mis tuleb ülesse? See siin,
Õpetaja: Mida me tegelikult teeme? Mõtleme, Mida me teeme praegu? Me kirjutame. Sellise koodirea on ju. Võrdub Selected City Id, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, aga nüüd on niimoodi, et kui ma Vaatan seda venti. City Strop Town Event New City Selected Selected City Id Kui. See kõnetab mind niimoodi paremini on kohe arusaadav on. Väga. Hea, kui ma ikka tunnen, et see meetod on kuidagi rets või midagi taolist, et ma pean siia sisse tulema vaatama.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis on Mõeldav, aga ma näitan alternatiivi. Me saame siin samamoodi teha. Ma Viitan siin, et. Kuule, Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Võrdusmärk. Saa sina uus sisu, see Event, mis tuleb alt, mis juba tulebki. Tegelikult. Aa City Id na,
Õpetaja: Noh, kurat, ma ei õnnestu. Ma tahan seda dollari märki, aga, noh, Ma panen seda, Event.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi on lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Alt Tuleb alt, Tuleb ju number Ja siis selle välju tuleb.
Õpetaja: Ja siin ma lihtsalt kirjutan, nagu, et kuule, kui tuleb alt Event Selected City It, saab endale uue väärtuse. Üks võrdlusmärk, mis iganes. Ja. No nüüd on meil see, et Meil on. Näed, see. See kood siin
Õpetaja: on tühi. Tegelt keegi seda ei kasuta. Pole Seda sinist veel eest ära võtnud, aga tegelikult seda Keegi Ei, kasuta,
Õpetaja: et saab kirjutada Selle sees
Õpetaja: saab ka teha eraldi meetodeid. Ja see on nagu Up to us to decide. Nagu, et Kuidas me peame Aa, lihtsamaks ja paremaks.
Õpetaja: Minu öeldes seda, et kui Cloud teeb mulle frontend koodi,
Õpetaja: siis tema pigem vaikimisi eelistab seda inline I. See on rea sees.
Õpetaja: Rea sees. Muudatused inline versus meetod. See töötab täpselt samamoodi nagu Vaatame, et nagu ee, tulen siia,
Õpetaja: noh, on muutunud, Tartu, et see on nagu meie mängumaa. No igal asjal on omad plussid miinused
Õpetaja: alati. Siis peab nagu neid natuke nagu kaaluma ja mõtlema nagu kuidas meile tundub.
Õpetaja: Ja minu jaoks on hästi lihtne. Ma olen seda varem ka öelnud, et minu jaoks on alati tegelikult koodi Loetavus on kuningas,
Õpetaja: et ma ei juhindu sellest, mida Cloud Code üks päev tõesti pakkus ühele koodile, Nagu, mis siin toimub. Mina tahtsin teha paarist koodireast eraldi meetodit,
Õpetaja: Sest mina tahtsin lugeda nagu raamat. Tema arvas, et kood on nagu, et ei ole vaja nagu nimelist meetodit,
Õpetaja: aga Siis ongi see nagu. Aa, Mina ütleksin nagu sellele koodile niimoodi. Tõesti ka, et jah. Okei, Keerukus tuleb, juurde et on jälle mingi meetod Ja asjad, Aga lihtsalt koodi. Loetavus. Meil on savi. Ega see palju see tähemärk ja siin ja seal üldse maksab nagu midagi, onju?
Õpetaja: No Eks ta ka midagi maksab. Kõik need asjad tuleb ju laadida. Vaata, onju Brauserisse ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga nagu ma pigem nagu eelistan nagu Midagi, mida sa saad lugeda võimalikult hästi kui raamatut.
Õpetaja: Aga jällegi mõtlen, et kindlasti Igal pool on nagu mingisugused piirid.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et Mõni vend võib päris hulluks ka minna, kui ta võtaks võibolla niukse mindset. I. Ta tahab tõesti ka kõiki lugeda. Nagu raamatut saab igast fookus fookust teha. Aga see tekitab ikkagi mingisugust keerukust ka juurde,
Õpetaja: et, ee, kui sul on ikka tuhat meetodit, seal, kõik teevad midagi, siis Võibolla see ei ole ka hea lähenemine. Kuskil on see tasakaal.
Õpetaja: Ja, noh, niukseid asju te tegelikult, ee, päris lõpus õpite kuskil töö juures. Ja Ja siis ei saa ka mõelda, et see üks projekt, kus te nagu töötate ja asjad, nagu tehakse, on tingimata absoluutne tõde. Vaata, Kuidas võiks asju teha?
Õpetaja: Mõned Asjad, on ka niimoodi, et keegi keegi Jüri
Õpetaja: Lhv. Ee, valib. Cold Fusion I. Vaata, et terve ülejäänud elu kõik kannatavad. Vaata, on ju samamoodi. Võib olla mingi projektiga, et alguses on valitud mingisugune muster
Õpetaja: ja siis ongi nagu seda, et poole projekti peal on nagu. Või Noh, see asi on juba elanud viis aastat, et võibolla. Tegelikult aeg on veits edasi läinud. Võibolla võiks kuidagi teistmoodi natukene olla või? Või kellegile meeldiks mingi uus lähenemine.
Õpetaja: Siis on see, et sa ei hakka lihtsalt lõhkuma seda olemasolevat asja ja palvetama, et Midagi katki ei tee Selleks, et minna mingi uue stiili peale ära, vaid siis pannakse selle käekirjaga edasi.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma võin öelda, näiteks Lh, Kui ma olin Eesti energias, vot siis Oli küll. Ma mõtlesin, nagu
Õpetaja: ma töötasin. Ee, tegin kunagi Ee Bloombergi rakendusega, mis jagab põhimõtteliselt energia Optsioonid, põhimõtteliselt futuurid.
Õpetaja: Finantsinstrumendid
Õpetaja: ja Bloombergil on oma mingi api, mille vastu saab minna. Pole klassikaline rest api, vaid oli mingi väga rõve süsteem. Pidin kasutama ühte väga rõvedat Scripti laadset keelt, et selle asjaga suhelda. Ja väga palju koodi oli. Tegelikult on ka veel funktsioonid.
Õpetaja: Sa saad Kirjutada skripte ja koode andmebaasi sees
Õpetaja: Ja mul. Oli siis kaks maailma, mis mängisid omavahel kokku. Ja mitte ainult kaks. Oli see tobe
Õpetaja: tagide Süsteemis Niukene Rooting Aa laadne aa Niiöelda keel või raamistik mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Aa, millest ma pidin aru saama, mis suhtes andmebaasiga ja andmebaasis ta käivitas mingit E.
Õpetaja: Päris kripto. Nagu ka jälle koodi. Ja siis see kood seal toimetas siis valdavalt tabelitega ja veergudega.
Õpetaja: Aa, tabelid olid disainitud Selles mõttes hästi, et oli klassikaline. Aa värk, et Ee Underscore. See
Õpetaja: kõik sõnad on eraldatud talakriipsudega. Fine Tabeli nimed, Veeru nimed Tabeli nimed Olid ainsuses, vist, kuigi. Noh, see seal võib olla mõlemat pidi, Aga mis mind nagu ajas hulluks ja ma mõtlesin, et mul ülikama, mina nagu seda Jama ei jätka. Vaata, oli see, et see, kes selle asja oli kokku kirjutanud, kunagi teinud
Õpetaja: selle põhi põhiasja ära, millel oli vaja teha uut asja juurde.
Õpetaja: Miski põhjusel. Ta oli seal selles plskl is võtnud kasutule muutujate nimes.
Õpetaja: Kaasnike, sa kirjutad koodi, sul on muutuja
Õpetaja: Ja selle asemel, et kasutada seal Camel. Case I
Õpetaja: saavad hästi lihtsalt aru, et tegemist on muutujaga. Ta kasutas naljakas, mis tähendab seda et Muutuja Nimed olid samasuguses kirjaviisis nagu tabeli nimed ja veeru nimed.
Õpetaja: Ja Loen siis sellist koodi.
Õpetaja: Kus koodi sees ongi? Viited ka päriselt nagu Tabelitele ja veergude nimedele. Ja muutujad on ka selle sama niiöelda konventsiooniga. Tegelikult, see on täielik absurd,
Õpetaja: nagu niipea, kui mina hakkasin ise oma koodi tegema niimoodi, et mul nagu programmilised muutujad olid. Nagu Camel. Case oli mul nagu kaugelt võimalik ka kohe aru saada, et
Õpetaja: kas see Nüüd on mingi tabeliandmed. Vaata mul seal objekti sees on. Ma midagi toimetan. Või Ma nüüd viitan praegult Tabeli nimele või Tabeli veerule, et Mul oli küll Niukene.
Õpetaja: Ee, et. Noh, siis ongi see. Vaata täpselt see tunne, Vaata, et vahel mingisugune vend ees valib mingisuguse lähenemise ja, Noh, päriselus peaks hoidma seda ee, lähenemist.
Õpetaja: No mina otsustasin siis, et mina ikkagi ei teinud. Ma teadsin, et. Ee. Noh, kui keegi kunagi Minu koodi loeb. Ee, versus seda teist koodi. Siis minu meelest on võimalik vähe paremini aru saada.
Õpetaja: Ah, Ee, rohkem nagu väga midagi ei jõuagi. Aeg ongi läbi. Tegelikult Kuidas tänane päev tundus? No ma teen, kui mitte. Aa, ma ei taha. Kui mi? Tähendab, ma ei, tea, Kuidas me teeme siis, kuidas me selle lahenduse teeme? Rida kolmteist.
Õpetaja: Kas on setter meetod või on otsekood?
Õpetaja: Rida Kood tail, kolmteist rida, kood mul kolmteist. No mis asja kommitiga on? Näha? Mis siin ennem oli?
Õpetaja: Ennem oli niimoodi kui teid rohkem kõnetab. See ongi küsimus, mis suured Viljaga saab teha.
Õpetaja: Ole vastust. Hea küll, seipäeb jälle. Ei pea mitte midagi vastama.
Õpetaja: Aa, saame ammu uuesti kokku. Aga kuidas muidu? Päev tundus Veits Raske jälle, on ju?
Õpetaja: No võibolla. Palun kasutage aega. Lugege, Vaadake, ma tean, et aega pole ja ja nii edasi, aga kuskilt peab nagu. Midagi.
Õpetaja: Jah, reedesest päevas. Kas kui. Niimoodi vaikselt hakake vaatama? Need leheküljed ei ole seal väga pikad. Te ei pea neid videosid vaatama, Aga te saate videosid vaadata. Mina läks. Oleme samal joonel. Ee, siis on nii.
Õpetaja: Panen selle ka kinni.
Õpetaja: Tänas tänase päeva Staffi videolink on juba olemas.